les chefs d'état-major monsieur le
délégué général pour l'armement Monsieur
le Secrétaire général Madame la
Directrice Générale mes chers collègues
nous sommes heureux monsieur le ministre
de vous accueillir
après une première édition qui a eu en
juillet dernier et nous entrons
maintenant dans le vif du sujet avec ce
projet de loi de finance pour 2023 qui
est un une étape évidemment
particulièrement importante tant pour
l'exécutif que pour le Parlement
vous avez souhaité monsieur le ministre
est accompagné pour cette audition par
les principaux responsables du ministère
et les responsables de nos armées le
séma le des Géa Lega l'échelle
d'état-major des armées de terre de
l'air et de l'espace de la Marine et la
DGS je leur adresse à toute à vous
madame et à vous tous insalu
cordial et amicale tout en adressant des
félicitations particulières aux délégués
général à l'armement et au secrétaire
général pour leur entrée en fonction
ainsi qu'à Madame Alice Guitton au
moment où elle va quitter ses propres
fonctions
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de vous le
faire savoir Monsieur le Ministre cette
rencontre est importante pour le Sénat
et donc pour mettre en oeuvre ce
dialogue
nous auquel nous attachons évidemment la
plus grande importance
vous savez que les chefs d'état-major et
les principaux responsables qui vous
entourent seront eux-mêmes auditionnées
dans les semaines qui viennent soit en
commission soit par les rapporteurs
budgétaires et donc nous aurons
l'occasion d'approfondir un certain
nombre de points plus longuement et donc
c'est pour ça que je vous propose que
nous consacrions le plus longtemps
possible à l'échange entre vous-même
monsieur le ministre et nos collègues
qui ont évidemment de nombreuses
questions je pense notamment aux
rapporteur et donc si vous le voulez
bien et je crois que vous l'avez accepté
après votre intervention liminaire je ne
donnerai donc la parole en priorité à
nous rapporteurs pour avis sur le projet
de loi de finances puis à l'ensemble de
nos collègues et donc vous même et
l'ensemble de l'équipe qui vous entoure
pourront après répondre aux
interventions et aux questions qui vous
seront posées alors Monsieur le Ministre
cette audition et particulièrement
importante car c'est en vérité le
premier budget depuis le la guerre russe
en Ukraine l'agression de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine tournant majeur dont il
faut évidemment tirer tous les
enseignements tant en termes
géopolitique en termes militaire pour
notre continent tout entier et pour
notre pays particulièrement la remontée
en puissance des armées françaises a été
initié des 2015 pour répondre à une
menace venue du Sud qui reste
malheureusement d'actualité
l'instabilité du continent africain La
Teste encore bien évidemment mais la
réactivation de la menace cette fois-ci
venue de l'Est que nous avions peut-être
probablement sous-estimé pose bien
évidemment des questions nouvelles
appelant aussi des réponses nouvelles et
sûrement des moyens
ce budget constitue par ailleurs une
étape importante dans la mise en oeuvre
de la loi de programmation militaire
2019-2025 la marche à 3 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires et donc franchi
avec un budget de près de 44 milliards
d'euros nous vous en donnons acte bien
volontiers et je souhaite en donner acte
au président de la République qui a de
nombreuses reprises confirmer cette
volonté de maintenir l'esprit et le
contenu de la loi de programmation
militaire dont je rappelle qu'elle avait
fait ici l'objet d'un vote très
important 326 voix sur 348
et donc
nous vous en donnons d'autant plus hâte
que nous connaissons par ailleurs ici au
Sénat les multiples tensions qui pèsent
sur le budget de l'État et les
circonstances financières difficiles qui
résultent des crises multiples que nous
supportons
ceci posé l'augmentation budgétaire de
7% et est important mais elle pose la
question de l'inflation l'inflation dont
les estimations des organes officiels de
l'État la projette à deux à 6,5% en 2022
et peut-être plus de 4% en 2023 c'est
évidemment pour nous tous pour nous tous
le principal point d'achoppement et le
principal point de questionnement de ce
budget certes la technique budgétaire
fournit des réponses à court terme
puisque l'utilisation des reports en
charge sur les années suivantes est
évidemment toujours possible mais même
si votre prédécesseur avait justement eu
à cœur de réduire ses reports sur la
durée de la LPM parce que l'aéroport
doivent à un moment ou un autre être
réglé et donc ce n'est que repousser
l'effort un peu plus loin il en effet un
risque d'affronter ensuite dans les
années à venir le retour de la fameuse
bosse budgétaire qu'on a connu dans le
passé et qui est pénalisante pour la
réalisation des investissements
indispensables et attendu par nos forces
armées
enfin ce budget est un budget de
transition vers la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire nous espérons
que vous nous donnerez peut-être
quelques pistes de réflexion à ce sujet
sinon sur le fond au moins sur le
calendrier et sur la méthode auquel nous
attachons la plus grande importance vous
le savez j'ai eu l'occasion de de vous
le dire monsieur le ministre le Sénat
qui est un pôle de stabilité dans la vie
politique actuelle le Sénat souhaite
être associé de près dès que ce cela se
sera dès que cela sera possible
associé à ce travail et nos débats sur
le PLF 2023 auront nécessairement un
impact sur la définition de cette
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
un travail de fond est évidemment
nécessaire car cette LPM sera
fondamentale c'est en vérité l'avenir de
la France comme puissance européenne et
comme puissance mondiale qui se joue et
c'est donc tout simplement de la
sécurité des Français dont il s'agit les
forces sera-t-il à l'échelle des enjeux
les conditions de la fin de l'exécution
pour 2022 et le PLF 2023 vont déjà nous
apporter un certain nombre d'éléments de
réponse mais dans l'immédiat monsieur le
ministre je vais vous laisser la parole
pour vous nous présenter les grands
enjeux du PLF 2023 vos objectifs mais
aussi en franchise les difficultés que
vous identifiez à ce stade car il faut
nous parler carte sur table
je donnerai après immédiatement après
votre prise de parole je donnerai la
parole à nous rapporteurs comme je
voulais annoncer puis à l'ensemble de
nos collègues et ainsi s'insta le
dialogue que bien évidemment nous
souhaitons je vous rappelle que c'est
audition est captée et elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et j'ai cru comprendre
qu'elle suscitait beaucoup d'attention
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président de
commission des affaires étrangères à la
défense mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
est-ce que vous me permettez monsieur le
Président de démarrer mon propos par un
point qui n'est pas lié à la l'examen
des crédits pour le finance 2023 mais
sur un point d'actualité et rendre
compte au Sénat d'une décision que le
Président de la République sur
proposition du chef d'état-major des
armées ici présent a pris hier au soir
et que je souhaite communiquer à la
présentation nationale et donc de par la
même à l'ensemble de nos concitoyens au
regard de la situation sur le flanc
oriental de l'OTAN regarde de la
violence avec laquelle évidemment les
combats s'inscrivent en Ukraine dans
cette guerre menée par la Fédération de
Russie présent de la République a décidé
de rehausser notre posture défensive de
escalatoires cela va sans dire sur le
flanc Est de l'Europe en déployant une
compagnie renforcée de véhicules blindés
de combats d'infanterie en Roumanie
ainsi que un escadron de Charles Leclerc
et que donc nous continuons dans le
cadre de nos missions
de défense et de dissuasion de
protection du flan oriental de l'Europe
d'accompagner évidemment ces pays
notamment la Roumanie qui est un pays
évidemment ami à Lyon présent évidemment
dans l'alliance de l'OTAN et sur lequel
nous devons cette solidarité nous allons
également continuer à renforcer notre
posture de défense en Lituanie dans
lequel des rafales seront également
déployés et en Estonie une compagnie
d'infanterie légère renforcée sera
également déployée dans les tous
prochains jours calendrier entre la fin
du mois d'octobre et le tout le courant
du mois de novembre des armées
évidemment pourra répondre à vos
interrogations le président de la
République m'a demandé de rendre compte
au Parlement de cette décision dans le
cadre évidemment de nos alliances et
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir jeudi
lors de la ministérielle de l'OTAN qui
se tiendra à Bruxelles j'imagine qu'on
aura l'occasion d'y revenir dans le
contenu des questions tout à l'heure
puisque cela va évidemment impacter
notre modèle d'armée aussi pour l'avenir
et donc la prochaine loi programmation
militaire peut-être aussi avant de
rentrer dans le contenu des crédits pour
2023 puisque monsieur le Président vous
avez publiquement rappelé à quel point
le le Sénat souhaitait être associé
singulièrement cette commission aux
travaux de la reprogrammation militaire
peut-être rendre compte publiquement
d'une conversation que nous avons eu en
privé vous et moi si vous mis autorisez
il est clair que nous ne souhaitons pas
construire cette programmation militaire
de la même manière que d'habitude déjà
parce qu'il y a pas beaucoup de suspense
personne n'imagine un seul instant que
la copie du gouvernement et du président
de la République sont une copie dans
lesquelles les crédits diminueraient en
tout cas on n'a pas raboter nous-mêmes
les crédits que je vous propose dans un
instant de voter en augmentation que
souvent les livres blancs dans le passé
sont d'esprit polémique ont parfois été
créé pour habiller malheureusement des
réductions de crédit et que
malheureusement aussi les différents
travaux qui ont été menés ces dernières
années sur la revue nationale
stratégique était bon quand je dis
malheureusement ils étaient bons c'est
qu'ils avaient pointé du doigt un
certain nombre de dangers sur lequel la
République française peut être exposée
soit pour ses intérêts soit pour sa
population
terrorisme bien évidemment mais aussi ce
que nous connaissons actuellement en
Europe centrale et donc on a évidemment
un devoir de réactivité dans la
construction c'est pas programmation
militaire et donc de manière peut-être
un peu différente nous souhaitons la
construire avant même le dépôt et la
présentation au Conseil des ministres
dans une plus grande intimité si vous
m'autorisez ce mot avec les deux
chambres peut-être d'ailleurs parfois
sur certains travaux de manière commune
mais aussi bien souvent de manière
séparée parce que les deux chambres ont
une identité parfois sur ces sujets qui
peuvent être intéressantes de ne pas
abîmer ou ne niveler par le banc en tout
cas c'est présente comme mission
évidemment qui le décideront et je vous
en êtes d'accord monsieur le Président
les premiers groupes de travail pourront
se réunir notamment avec les grands
chefs ici présents du ministère un
premier groupe de travail sur les
réserves un deuxième groupe de travail
sur le plan famille on y reviendra
peut-être puis bien sûr des groupes de
travail spécifiques nos alliances les
questions évidemment capacitaires la
part d'innovation autant de groupes de
travail que
pas changé et quels sont les menaces qui
continuent évidemment de nous guetter
voilà les deux points luminaires merci
de m'avoir permis de le faire sur la
méthodologie avec le Sénat et peut-être
aussi sur cette actualité
malheureusement que nous connaissons sur
le flanc oriental de l'Europe peut-être
aussi que le format peut interroger mais
créer plus intimité avec le Parlement
dans la manière de travailler applique à
la fois évidemment d'être capable de
créativité ce sont les groupes de
travail mais aussi de rendre compte je
suis frappé de voir c'est un point sur
lequel je serai aussi heureux d'avoir
l'impression du Sénat c'est de voir que
les crédits augmentent à la fois tout le
monde le salue et en même temps cela
pose aussi la question de
l'acceptabilité sociale sociétale de
voir des crédits augmentés autant en se
posant la question mais au fond est-ce
que c'est vraiment utile est-ce que
l'argent va au bon endroit quels sont
les effets militaires réels en
protection en sécurité pour le pays
c'est un débat dont alors que nous vous
proposons des augmenter et que le Sénat
en plus amène la confiance et le vote en
général de ces crédits en augmentation
c'est un débat que nous pouvons pas
évidemment éluder et donc le mystère des
armées est particulier 5 ans que je suis
ministre mon quatrième poste ministériel
néanmoins c'est le seul ministère dans
lequel l'ordinateur principal
responsable politique devant le
Parlement a des ordonnateurs délégués
autour de moi qui engage des blocs par
milliards parfois et ça c'est une
particularité dans l'organisation de la
République dans notre manière de
travailler et donc aussi je pense que
nous aurons un devoir de rendre compte
de manière très démocratique et
peut-être de manière encore plus fine à
l'avenir de la manière dont ces crédits
sont utilisés dès lors qu'ils augmentent
en général les crédits en diminution
font l'objet de contestation ou de
questions au gouvernement les crédits
qui augmentent en général méritent une
autre méthodologie de contrôle peut-être
plus technique à certains égards et cela
explique évidemment le format que je
vous ai proposé pour cette audition pour
ne pas plus attendre
à PLF des crédits
comment dire loi de programmation
militaire donc des crédits sous
programmation qui sont par définition
toujours prévisibles et en continuité je
pense qu'effectivement avant de parler
des dépenses vous l'avez dit en donnant
acte au gouvernement dans sa copie qui
vous est proposée qu'effectivement cette
année la parole est tenue sur la courbe
des recettes notamment en rappelant ces
chiffres puisque en crédit de paiement
nous étions il y a quelques années en
2017 32,3 milliards d'euros nous vous
proposons cette année pour 2023 un
budget en augmentation de 36% avec cette
première marche à 3 milliards d'euros
pour le porter le budget des armées en
crédit de paiement à 43,9 milliards
d'euros en autorisé aussi engagement
pareil 40,8 milliards d'euros en 2017 et
52,8 milliards d'euros en 2023 donc en
clair la parole est tenue sans esprit
polémique c'est une rupture aussi avec
le passé ou parfois les lois de
programmation pouvait avoir un décalage
en a eu en CP et qu'à la fin
malheureusement la loi de programmation
n'apparaissait pas forcément toujours
sincère de vendre Parlement là pour le
coup on a quelque chose qui se fait à
l'euro près sur le volet des recettes
vous m'avez interrogé sur l'inflation
j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure monsieur
le Président vous avez raison c'est un
défi auquel nous devons répondre avec
les outils qui sont les nôtres mais là
aussi je vous répondrai en tout cas
cette première marche à 3 milliards elle
permet aussi de se situer dans le
concert des nations notamment en Europe
au sein de l'OTAN sur lequel il est
difficile de se comparer un certain
nombre d'articles de prêts sont sortis
ces jours-ci enfin tous les pays que
l'on compare sont pas tous puissances
doté tous les pays que nous comparerons
n'ont pas tous des Outre-mer sur lequel
nous devons exercer une souveraineté
sans être désagréable ou des obligeant
tous les pays que nous comparerons n'ont
pas toujours une armée d'emploi donc au
fond il est toujours parfois difficile
de comparer ce qui n'est pas toujours
comparable en tout cas les crédits
augmentent partout et dans les marches
évidemment d'augmentation la France fait
partie des pays qui augmentent notamment
le plus puissamment mais surtout qui n'a
pas attendu l'U pour l'augmenter ce qui
est quand même singularise de beaucoup
de pays y compris des pays de la hayon
Atlantique pour ne pas être trop long il
y a une réalité aussi c'est que les gros
morceaux des dépenses depuis 2018 j'en
ai terminé pour les recettes
ces effets de remontée en puissance
confirme et c'est particulièrement vrai
sur la modernisation des équipements
puisque vous le savez on avait discuté
lors de la précédente audition au mois
de juillet c'est la principale
affectation des augmentations de crédit
depuis 2017 puisque globalement c'est
équipements ces modernisation
d'équipements ont capté à eux seuls 41%
de la ressource supplémentaire depuis
2017 et globalement or dissuasion donc
ça c'est particulièrement clair
peut-être que les chefs d'état-major y
reviendront mais c'est un point qu'il
faut avoir en tête et en 2023 les
crédits de paiement pour les équipements
majeurs eux seront établis à 8,5
milliards d'euros en CP c'est à dire là
encore une augmentation de 5,6% depuis
2022 concrètement ça veut dire que ça se
traduit par des crédits de paiement
concrets en livraison des 2023 les
fusils d'assaut HK un lot de missile
Exocet un sous-marin nucléaire d'attaque
de la classe Barracuda le deuxième un
satellite Syracuse 4 13 mirage rénovés
13 rafales 9 18 chars Leclerc rénovés
dont d'ailleurs je faisais ça tout à
l'heure déclenchement là pour le coup
d'autorisation d'engagement
14,2 milliards d'euros en langage grand
public des commandes pour notamment 400
véhicules blindés légers Serval on
continue évidemment pour la remettre
terre cette rénovation historique une
capacité exploratoire en fond marin 42
rafales qui répond aussi à vos questions
de recomplètement des rafales d'export
questions que vous m'aviez posé en
juillet je vous avais donné rendez-vous
en le finance la réponse il trouve ici
19 stations navales de communication
satellitaire j'en passe il y a un blog
de dépenses monsieur le Président qui
est en continuité conversation que nous
avions privé il y a quelques jours c'est
évidemment la dissuasion dont on voit
bien au fond quand on va retravailler
sur la RNS on voit bien que la grammaire
de la dissuasion la voûte nucléaire pour
défendre les intérêts vitaux fait
évidemment partie des travaux sur lequel
le Sénat doit se pencher et dans les
semaines et moi qui viennent parce que
ça pose des questions évidemment de
modernisation pour l'avenir et donc les
crédits de paiement qui sont proposés
pour 2023 le seul dissuasion c'est 5,6
milliards d'euros en les crédits de
paiement pour 2023 sont en augmentation
de 318 millions d'euros ce qui n'a rien
négligeable notamment pour continuer à
moderniser la simulation pour continuer
à rendre comment dire intègre et très
sécurisé nos transmissions spécifiques
et un certain nombre d'investissement
divers néanmoins monsieur le Président
et Monsieur la sénateur il est clair que
2023 constitue un pivot vous l'avez dit
vous-même un pivot qui nous emmène dans
évidemment la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire mais surtout un
pivot qui tient compte du fameux rétex
Ukraine sur lequel le chef d'état-major
des armées avec l'ensemble des SEMS là
déjà à mettre en œuvre tout cela on
tirait un certain nombre d'enseignements
en disant comment on met à jour en
conduite ce que nous devions faire dans
le cas de programmation militaire en
regardant très cliniquement ce qui se
passe en Ukraine c'est à dire que je
vous ai dit jusqu'à présent que le
capacitaire avait beaucoup absorbé les
crédits nouveaux depuis 2017 c'est vrai
mais en 2023 la répartition va néanmoins
être un peu différente avec quelques
ajustements que je vous détaille tout de
suite un déjà sur le volet des
ressources humaines c'est un on parle
beaucoup d'équipements il y a pas
d'armée sans soldats il y a pas d'armée
sans sa famille il y a pas d'armée sans
réservistes ce sont évidemment des
sujets sur lesquels on va continuer de
se pencher pour les années qui viennent
mais globalement la copie que nous vous
présentons au vote pour 2023 une copie
avec 1500 créations de postes dans les
armées plutôt orientées renseignements
cybersécurité 1500 postes en 2023
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
c'est-à-dire autant que les trois
précédentes années ou globalement nous
étions sur des marches à 500 et TP là on
vous propose 1500 et TP en une seule
fois deuxième des choses évidemment PRM
sur lequel j'avais répondu à vos
nombreuses questions au mois de juillet
réforme en trois ans entamé évidemment
sur l'autorité de Florence Parly
désormais on est la troisième marche
avec les crédits que vous retrouverez
dans cette copie évidemment
l'intégration du point d'indice de la
fonction publique alors j'ai eu des
questions un peu curieuses à l'Assemblée
nationale qui disait enfin c'était pas
prévu en même temps une loi de
programmation n'est pas une loi de
fixation vers le ministère reste vivant
avec ce qui peut se passer donc on
conduit évidemment on prend aussi dans
les crédits parce qu'il est normal ça
aurait été curieux de ne pas faire le
l'augmentation du point d'indice pour le
seul ministère des armées donc
évidemment nous assumons cette décision
c'est plus 357 millions d'euros en 2023
et je vous parlais du plan famille qui
continue sa montée en puissance avec
globalement 180 millions d'euros dans
cette copie sachant que monsieur le
Président si vous en êtes d'accord je
vous propose de co-produire le plan
famille 2 en lien directement notamment
avec le Sénat puisque je compte avoir
une approche un peu nouvelle avec les
collectivités territoriales qui parfois
n'ont pas été mis de côté c'est pas vrai
mais en tout cas non pas forcément été
assez intégrés dans la manière ou un
territoire lorsqu'il a un régiment une
base navale une base aérienne ou une
entité de la DGA peut justement
améliorer le parcours de la famille du
combattant localement j'en sais quelque
chose comme élu de l'heure avec la base
aérienne 105 il y a du mieux et ça pour
le coup le retour territoire c'est je
veux dire du Sénat nous sera évidemment
précieux non l'autre volet sur lequel il
y a évidemment donc pas un pivot mais un
durcissement pour citer mon voisin de
droite important ce sont évidemment les
munitions ça c'est un rétex
lourd il est évidemment très structurant
munition et je rajouterais maintien en
conditions opérationnelles ces deux
jambes au fond qui font de notre armée
une armée d'emploi ça pour le coup le
schéma évidemment plus sachant que moi
sur cette affaire ce sont ces
propositions qui ont évidemment suscité
notre notre validation immédiate et donc
nous vous demandons de bien vouloir les
valider c'est globalement pour l'année
2023 5 milliards d'euros en plus pour le
seul maintien en conditions
opérationnelles dont je précise que 57%
des dépenses se réfléchit par la
maintenance de nos moyens aér dont on
sait très bien que leur disponibilité
reste toujours un enjeu pour nous tous
les munitions vous disaient c'est 2000
milliards d'euros que vous nous
proposons dans cette copie pour 2023
c'est à dire 500 millions d'euros de
plus que sur l'année 2022 c'est clé ça
veut dire 60 % de crédit en plus par
rapport à 2019 alors les millions et les
milliards ne veulent pas dire
grand-chose si on le dit autrement c'est
comment de 200 missiles de moyenne
portée c'est comment de 100 missiles
semblait qui par ailleurs font l'objet
d'une actualité livraison de 100
missiles RR Mika des bombes airsol 10
000 munitions 155 milles pour les canons
César là aussi désormais munitions bien
connues 50 millions de munitions c'est
une classe en tout cas de cible pour les
munitions de petits calibres des obus
pour les rafales bref une liste
importante mais qui vient donner du
concret sur notre capacité à remonter en
puissance sur nos stock de munitions
évidemment avec un effort majeur pour
les équipements individuels c'est la
troisième somme à savoir 1, milliards
d'euros gilet pare-balles treillis etc
dernier point un effort sur les
infrastructures vous visitez mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs beaucoup
d'unités de toutes les armées parfois
entre nos milliards à Paris et la
réalité bâtimentaire sur le terrain et
un petit délai une inertie parfois dans
la manière dont tout ça profite à la vie
quotidienne des forces armées nous en
sommes conscients et donc c'est un point
d'attention majeur avec 2 milliards
d'euros en crédit de paiement c'est à
dire pas des commandes mais vraiment des
travaux réalisés pour l'année 2023
sachant qu'il faut dissocier les
infrastructures militaires un nouveau
les nouveaux équipements pour les
sous-marins ou pour les rafales par
exemple ou pour le MRTT ou pour les
différents stations d'accueil pour les
équipements de la galaxie scorpion
infrastructure militaire pure si j'ose
dire et de l'autre côté les
infrastructures civiles en emprise
militaire en clair l'hébergement ou des
bâtiments collectifs que je pourrais
évidemment répondre à vos questions pour
conclure monsieur le Président ce que
vous avez promis de ne pas être long euh
j'essaie toujours de tenir mes promesses
peut-être deux points d'attention qu'il
ne faut pas prendre comme une fin en soi
mais comme le pivot pour la LPM à venir
le spatial et le cyber donc on voit bien
que ces deux sujets sont soumis à
exigences d'innovation
exigences aussi dans la compétition dans
lequel nous nous trouvons de manière
évidemment très claire là je crois qu'un
certain nombre de questions me seront
posées mais sur le spatial c'est 70-2
millions d'euros en CP en 2023 bon c'est
dual donc spatial militaire dont je vous
rencontre enfin on sait très bien que le
spatial civil peut aussi soutenir le
spatial militaire et pour cause il
s'agit de nos lanceurs en tout cas Diop
de théâtre Syracuse 4 son programme et
37 stations tactiques satellitaires la
livraison de ta satellite Syracuse 4 en
tant que tel j'en passe pareil pour le
cyber ou là je vous en parlais tout à
l'heure sur les efforts RH mais on voit
que c'est un enjeu alors il y a un enjeu
pour le territoire national dans le
ministère des armées n'est pas seul
compétent il y a un enjeu également
aussi sur les emprises militaires à
l'étranger on le voit notamment aussi
avec la guerre informationnelle qui peut
être menée désormais dans cette
hybridité en dessous du conventionnel
bien en dessous du de la voûte nucléaire
ça va sans dire en dessous aussi du
conventionnel classique tel que nous le
connaissons on a désormais aussi notre
guerre auquel nous devons faire face
c'est cette hybridité et évidemment le
cyber il prend toute sa part 2023 ça
sera aussi et ça sera mon dernier mot
une année de tulages pour notre BITD et
pour les opérations je vous avais rendu
compte en juillet et nous avons tenu le
calendrier de la manœuvre du Mali vers
le Niger c'est donc un nouvel agenda
aussi de présence française en Afrique
vous y étiez récemment monsieur le
Président qui ceux qui se qui se déroule
devant nous il faudra vous en rendre
compte dans le cadre de la RNS parce que
ce que nous avons y faire conditionner
évidemment la programmation militaire
l'émission de l'OTAN en direct et j'ose
dire ce que je viens vous annoncer tout
à l'heure montre bien que tout ça va
être très évolutif et donc conditionne
aussi ce que nous attendons de nos
armées les missions enusienne dont nous
parlons peu mais enfin nous continuons
d'être engagés la fin du Liban étant
évidemment peut-être une des plus
symboliques et évidemment les mécanismes
de LPM sur ces sujets restent inchangés
puisque nous continuons à être une armée
d'emplois dans les mécanismes de taux
assurance tout ce que vous connaissez
évidemment sont proposés dans cette
copie de crédit pour 2023 pour permettre
aux armées de continuer à travailler
économie de guerre c'est dans la feuille
de route du DGA ici présent à un moment
donné évidemment on peut pas gagner la
guerre de demain avec les équipements
d'hier pour autant on le voit bien aussi
la rusticité et la disponibilité des
équipements et la capacité à produire
vite font désormais partie aussi du
modèle d'armée donc au moment où l'armée
pivote fait œuvre de cohérence et
procède un certain nombre de
durcissements il faut donc aussi
embarquer la avec nous et ça
faut le faire de manière bienveillante
mais enfin on fait aussi de faire de
manière claire un peu comme les
gaullistes l'ont fait au début de
des années 58 59 60 dans lequel il y
avait aussi une réflexion stratégique
sur notre autonomie stratégique à passer
beaucoup par la dissuasion mais pas que
donc là aussi on est dans un moment à
mon avis de grande réflexion sur ce que
nous attendons de notre industrie de
défense donc aussi de ce que nous
attendons de nos coopérations avec un
certain nombre de pays je pense qu'il y
aura un certain nombre de questions sur
le SCAF sur lequel je pourrais revenir
et évidemment tout ça n'est rien sans
réfléchir aux forces morales que
l'expression que le Président de la
République a employé au discours de
Brienne le force morale c'est la
question de l'évolution du s&u une
secrétaire d'État pourra rendre compte
devant vous directement des travaux pas
la peine de parler de l'armée de demain
si on oublie la mémoire les anciens
combattants une secrétaire d'État peut
évidemment rendre compte devant vous de
la mission budgétaire qui est consacrée
évidemment à cette question et puis la
question des réserves que je peux
évidemment détailler devant vous mais
que je vous propose aussi de traiter
dans un des groupes de travail que nous
pouvons lancer dans le cadre de la
prochaine loi programmation militaire
mais sur lequel vous l'avez vu les
crédits sont évidemment prévus et
fléchés pour l'année 2023 monsieur le
président que je réponds tout juste à
votre question sur l'inflation ou est-ce
qu'on laisse les orateurs des groupes
parler
vivement à nos collègues rapporteurs
je pense qu'il y aura certainement des
questions sur ce sujet car j'ai dit que
c'était la un peu la pierre angulaire de
l'exécution du budget et même de la LPM
jusqu'en 2030 et donc sans plus attendre
je vais donner la parole à porteur et
avec la courtoisie légendaire de la
commission je vais céder la parole à
Dominique delaige notre collègue qui
rapporte les crédits défense à la
commission des finances chers collègues
merci monsieur le Président de votre
courtoisie que j'apprécie beaucoup et
qui me semble indispensable pour aborder
ce budget dans de bonnes conditions
entre nous nos deux commissions monsieur
le ministre rapidement quelques points
de vigilance que je voudrais relever
vous avez parlé de sincérité avec le
président Cambon je vous donne bien
volontiers actes que le budget 2023
respecte la LPM les autres points de vie
de vigilance que je voudrais évoquer en
termes de sincérité c'est d'abord la
question de l'inflation
je pense que le report de charge c'est
constitue une dette à l'intérieur de la
dette nous serons donc vigilants sur ce
point vous avez évoqué l'arrivée de
nouveaux équipements je m'en réjouis les
nouveaux équipements sont plus
sophistiqués il nécessite plus de budget
pour les maintenir en condition
opérationnelles c'est aussi un point de
vigilance point de vigilance aussi sur
les délais du Scaff et je laisserai mes
collègues de la commission qui sont plus
au fait de ces questions là que moi
d'approfondir mais je crois qu'on ne
peut pas envisager d'avancer sur le
remplacement du Charles de Gaulle sans
avoir réglé ce problème là vous avez
évoqué les munitions points de vigilance
je donne acte de l'augmentation des
crédits mais entre le moment où on les
commande et le moment où elles arrivent
il y a le problème de délai je voulais
l'évoquer enfin j'en aurais terminé en
bonjour monsieur le ministre que nous
sommes nombreux à avoir regretté de ne
pas avoir pu être associé à la révision
de la loi de programmation militaire en
2021 je prends acte bien volontiers des
propos que vous avez tenus tout à
l'heure sur la manière dont vous
envisagiez d'associer le Parlement à
l'écriture de la nouvelle je vous
remercie ainsi un cycle président et sa
courtoisie merci monsieur le rapporteur
spécial et donc nous allons continuer
cette fois-ci avec les rapporteurs de la
mission défense au sein de notre
commission en commençant par le 146
équipement des forces Cédric Perrin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre ce ministre au regard des
événements en Ukraine les autres pays
européens ont décidé d'investir
massivement on connaît la question des
Allemands ça fait un moment qu'elles en
parler même si c'est pas clair ça avance
significativement les Britanniques 100
milliards en 2030 avec comme véritable
objectif 80 milliards les Polonais 40
milliards et nous risquons de voir un
nouveau centre de gravité sur le
continent européen se mettre en place
nous demander leur redouter le
déclassement de la France si nous ne
mettons pas des moyens suffisants pour
rester dans la course c'est le ministre
vous le savez vous aurez besoin du Sénat
vous n'avez pas à nous craindre et notre
unique objectif ici aux autres et de
servir les intérêts de la France et de
nos armées nos précédents vote témoigne
de cette loyauté de notre sens des
responsabilités puisque la précédente
LPM a été je le rappelle adoptée à quasi
unanimité au Sénat je regarde ma
question nous observons des
investissements militaires massifs dans
des pays de pays étrangers Israël la
Corée du Sud notamment dans des pays
européens ou détriment du matériel
européen et évidemment pas acceptable
que nous distribuions des fonds
européens pour que les pays
bénéficiaires achètent du matériel à
l'étranger je pense particulièrement à
l'attitude de l'Allemagne que cela soit
sur les programmes de coopération sur le
Poséidon l'hélicoptère le 35 et quant à
sa défense antimicile elle pourrait être
israélienne comment peut-on aujourd'hui
raisonnablement la considérer comme un
partenaire alors que ces investissements
dans la défense sont tous américains
c'est une question que je vous pose
enfin Monsieur le Ministre à l'Assemblée
nationale au-delà des crédits de
paiement et des crédits d'équipement que
vous citez votre intervention se divise
par bloc vous annoncez le bloc de la
dissuasion nucléaire à 5,6 milliards de
crédit de paiement le bloc des
ressources humaines le bloc des missiles
dont acte mais est-ce que nous
conservons un modèle d'armée complet ou
est-ce que vous proposez un autre modèle
vous expliquer vouloir 18 Charles
Leclerc rénovés c'est très bien mais
quid du mgcs quid du panthère kf-51 quid
de l'acquisition massive de char coréen
par les Polonais si tout cela est mis en
oeuvre évidemment le les futurs
acquisitions du mgcs seront donc
caduques vous parlez d'un bloc avec 420
véhicules blindés vous parlez des
capacités d'exploration des fonds marins
mais on ignore ce que vous mettez dedans
vous intégrez la dissuasion dans un bloc
de défense c'est parfait de nous dire on
fait des satellites et on rénove les
mirages on achète probablement du Rafale
vous avez fait une liste intéressante
mais quelle est la vision future face au
SCAF et aux enjeux à venir type planeur
hypersoniques ou avions spatial mais
même vous avez évoqué le bloc avec une
commande de 2 milliards ça sur ton quel
bénéficiera à la France est-il articulé
avec ce que vous venez d'évoquer à
l'instant c'est-à-dire la démarche
d'économie de guerre dont nous voyons
malheureusement pour l'instant en tout
cas la mission n'a pas été dévoilée peu
d'effet dans les industries qu'on a
l'occasion de rencontrer dans nos
territoires et surtout au bout de
combien de temps est-ce que cela
produira des effets trois options sont
sur la table l'option de continuité
d'une LPM au fil de l'eau avec un étiage
budgétaire de Bercy l'option défendue
par le ma et la vôtre mais quel est-elle
vous allez peut-être nous parler d'une
copie différenciée mais que vis-à-vis
vous monsieur le ministre quelle vision
avez-vous merci beaucoup
merci les questions précises second
rapporteur pour le programme 146
toujours en équipement des forces Hélène
Conway
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
ministre vous l'avez rappelé 2023 est
une année charnière pivot mais oui du
contexte géopolitique nous ne pouvons
pas manquer une marche dans la
consolidation de notre appareil
militaire et ce qui rend finalement
l'exercice difficile cette année c'est
de ne pas avoir de cadrage et de ne pas
savoir exactement ce qui va ce qui va
entrer dans la LPM car nous n'avons
aucune visibilité sur ce qui sera validé
ou non des différentes copies qui ont
été rendues par les différents corps
d'armée à la fin de l'été et donc de ne
pas être certain que nous ferons
finalement les bons choix dès cette
année une LPM c'est l'opposé du court
terme et la somme des divers besoins et
2023 donc s'inscrire dans une vision sur
le long terme dont nous avons vraiment
besoin alors moi je vais rentrer dans le
détail du budget d'abord l'article 4
dispose que les surcoût net OPEX initent
doivent être financés en
interministérielle ce dispositif a été
parti mobilisé en 2021 et compte tenu de
la réorganisation de barkhane et de la
mise en place de la mission aigle
pourriez-vous nous indiquer à combien
est évalué le surcoût net un dispositif
de financement interministériel est-il
envisagé quel montant sera prélevé le
cas échéant sur le programme 146
d'autre part l'article 5 de la LPM
actuel prévoit des crédits
supplémentaires pour compenser la hausse
du coût des carburants où sont ces
crédits j'ajouterai que 350 millions
seront consacrés à la revalorisation de
la valeur du point d'indice de la
fonction publique comment sont-ils
financés enfin le président de la
République a annoncé la création d'un
fond spécial de 100 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour lui crènes là
encore se pose la question du
financement alors bien sûr tous ces
crédits crédits entamment les 3
milliards d'augmentation il est pas
question de les contester mais nous
aimerions mieux comprendre les
arbitrages qui permettent de les
financer à enveloppe globale constante
enfin pourriez-vous évoquer le format
rafale à l'horizon 2025 qui souffre d'un
décalage d'une année entre la commande
et les livraisons des appareils qui sont
d'ailleurs livrés une cadence plutôt
soutenue et ce manque d'appareils
disponibles d'ailleurs une incidence sur
le nombre d'heures de vol des pilotes
qui est passé de 180 à 150 heures de vol
par an c'est tout capacité d'autant plus
problématique les derniers mirages 2007
ont été retirés du service
envisagez-vous d'acquérir des appareils
à l'étranger pour combler cette sous
capacité je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue je rappelle pour
ceux qui nous suivent que la tradition
ici à la Commission de façon générale de
la défense fait que sur chaque programme
nous avons toujours un rapporteur de la
majorité de l'opposition
et donc cela nourrit notre débat
nous allons passer au programme 144
environnement et prospective de la
politique de défense
on va commencer donc par Pascal Alizard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Madame la Directrice Générale
messieurs les officiers généraux et
délégués généraux il est je le crois
difficile de détacher cet exercice
budgétaire de l'actualité immédiate sans
pour autant monsieur le ministre négligé
la prospective l'innovation et le
renseignement c'est le propre du
programme
144 je voudrais donc soulever quatre
points d'attention relatifs aux études
amont et au financement de l'abbé TD
premier point ce sont les crédits
consacrés aux études amont qui
augmenteront à hauteur de 1,5% en crédit
de paiement pour atteindre le milliard
d'euros prévu par la LPM et on s'en
réjouit en revanche les autorisations
d'engagement elles diminueront
légèrement de l'ordre de -02%
pourriez-vous nous préciser les raisons
de cette diminution qui a priori
impactera nég jugement le domaine de
l'information et du renseignement
classique Horace toujours en lien avec
les études amont mais cette fois dans
l'aéronautique lors de votre déplacement
à Berlin en septembre dernier vous êtes
montré très affirmatif en indiquant je
cite que le SCAF pour lequel des études
amont ont été lancées le Scaff est
attendu autant par Berlin que par Paris
et ce projet se fera on ne peut pas être
plus direct je me permets de vous citer
pourriez-vous nous indiquer à la date où
nous échangeons aujourd'hui où en sont
les discussions au niveau politique
entre la France et l'Allemagne ainsi
qu'au niveau industriel en terre bus et
d'assaut et si un calendrier précis sur
ce projet peut être attendu à brève
échéance second point
s'agissant du financement de la BITD le
13 juillet dernier le président de la
République a rappelé et à juste titre sa
vigilance face aux conséquences des
projets tax européenne sur
l'investissement dans les innovations de
défense or il semblerait que certaines
dispositions de la proposition directive
de voir de vigilance en matière de
durabilité des entreprises
adoptées par la Commission en février
dernier pourrai s'avérer problématique
si elle devait être appliquée à
l'industrie de défense je pense en
particulier à l'intégration de l'aval de
la chaîne de valeur ce qui pourrait
poser problème s'agissant de matériel de
guerre de leur exportation ou encore la
vérification du respect de certaines
obligations par une autorité
indépendante ce qui bien évidemment
soulève des questions en matière de
sécurité et de confidentialité
pourriez-vous me suis mise sous indiquer
ce cantenfert votre ministère afin
d'éviter que cette directive se traduise
par des contraintes trop lourdes voire
par des sanctions à l'encontre des
entreprises de la BITD troisième point
c'est un projet de vente de la pépite
électronique excelia un potentiel
acquéreur étranger qui pose à nouveau la
question du financement et de la
protection de nos entreprises comment
vous servir suivent-elles cette vente et
quatrième et dernier point après
l'abandon du projet Province de France
de votre prédécesseur et à la lumière de
l'actualité de la guerre en Ukraine vous
avez annoncé des budgets significatifs
sur les munitions mais la relance d'une
filière munition de petit calibre en
France vous semble-t-elle être
d'actualité voilà monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie merci Monsieur rapporté
à massy-pascal Yannick vogrenard
oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre alors où nous vous
recevons la guerre en Ukraine entre dans
une nouvelle phase durcissement dont
l'issue ne peut que nous inciter à
revenir à la question fondamentale du
rôle de la France au sein de l'OTAN et
durant quelques tenir compte tenu de ce
moyen actuel et de ceux que nous
envisageons nous doter dans le cadre de
la future loi de programmation militaire
2024-2030
rappelons que le programme 144 que je
partage avec mon collègue Pascal Alizard
s'intitule environnement et prospective
de la politique de défense il est donc
au coeur de la réflexion qu'il doit
collectivement nous conduire à
identifier les enseignements du conflit
en Ukraine pour les traduire en nouvelle
priorité pour l'innovation de dépenses
nous avons également évoqué les angles
morts de l'industrie de défense
française en matière de drones armée de
munitions rodeuse et de défense aérienne
du territoire pour ne citer que quelques
exemples
il ne s'agit donc pas seulement de
réagir à la guerre en Ukraine mais aussi
d'anticiper les menaces futures
ma question est simple est-il crédible
qu'en seulement deux mois et dans
l'urgence une nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire soit déjà
budgétaire dans une fourchette comprise
entre 435 milliards d'euros pour 7 ans
sur la demande des états majeurs et 375
milliards pour Bercy
n'est-ce pas surprenant de discuter
d'une échelle de coups préalablement aux
indispensables besoins
quant à la proposition de Bercy pouvant
considérer qu'elle est un peu ubuesque
la période que nous traversons et ça a
été rappelé et probablement la plus
préoccupante depuis 1945 et la crise des
missiles de Cuba en 1962 notre société
ne démocratie peut être mise en danger
nous liberté fondamentales collectives
et individuelles peuvent être remises en
cause
dans ce contexte monsieur le ministre
vous cache pas que j'ai plus confiance
dans la rigueur militaire de nos chefs
d'états majeur que dans la rigueur
budgétaire de Bercy
ma seconde question est très courte
et porte sur nos moyens de
renseignements
la loi de programmation
2019-2025 prévoyait 1500 nouveaux
emplois pour renforcer les domaines de
la super défense et du renseignement les
crédits de fonctionnement et
d'équipements pour 2023 continue de
progresser et c'est un élément
incontestablement positif en revanche
j'observe que les moyens humains du
renseignement extérieur vont stagner à
hauteur d'un peu plus de 5700 équivalent
en plein au moment où la Chine pour
information
emploie 100 000 cybercombattants où la
Russie et la Corée du Nord se livre au
piratage et au rançonnage informatique à
la désinformation de masse notamment en
Afrique et nous avons subi les
conséquences militaires et politiques
est-ce que nous sommes monsieur le
ministre bon niveau par rapport à nos
agresseurs mais aussi par rapport à nos
alliés britanniques et allemands dans ce
domaine essentiel du renseignement
extérieur je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur merci
Yannick nous allons passer maintenant au
programme 178 préparation et emploi des
forces avec une intervention d'abord
d'Olivier sigoletti merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre en tant
que rapporteur du programme 178 de
question synthétique vous avez annoncé
le budget dans le cas du PDF 2023
portant le MCO et donc l'entretien
programmé du matériel pratiquement
samilla c'est une marge de 500 millions
d'euros supplémentaires que vous avez
annoncé or notre commission en
travaillant sur les premières années et
les premières annuités de programmation
avait identifié un besoin de 1,2
milliards en matière d'entretien
programmée du matériel et cela avant que
vous soyez en charge de de ce budget
mais également avant l'annonce des
ventes de rafales qui ont décalé
l'arrivée de nouveaux équipements dans
nos armées et les besoins qui en
découlent d'entretien d'aéronef
vieillissant
ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre c'est 500 millions sont-ils
suffisants est-ce qu'ils répondent aux
besoins de nos armées on sait
l'incidence du MCO et de l'entretien
programmé du matériel sur l'activité
opérationnelle est-ce que dans ces
conditions il est possible de préparer
la haute intensité et enfin deuxième
question monsieur le ministre qui
rejoint la question de ma collègue
Hélène Conway Mouret concernant les Opex
le président de la République a annoncé
en ce début d'année 2022 le retrait de
l'opération barkhane du Mali
ces choses faites depuis le 15 août de
cette année
barkhane avait un coup d'environ 700
millions d'euros par an environ 2
millions d'euros par jour qu'est-ce
qu'il en sera dans ce nouveau format
avec ce redéploiement au Niger et au
Tchad vous avez évoqué bien sûr une
augmentation des OPEX notamment dans le
cadre de la mission de réassurance de
l'OTAN avec la mission aigle comment
est-ce que ces deux éléments vont se
vont se compenser voir s'additionner
merci
merci Monsieur rapporteur merci Olivier
second rapporteur sur le 178 Michel
gréaume merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre en tant que
rapportrice du programme 178 je veille
particulièrement au service de soutien
vous connaissez mon inquiétude
récurrente et mon attention à
l'évolution des effectifs du service de
santé des armées qui est accusé un
déficit pour les médecins du premier
recours de 136 postes en 2021 cette
année pour la première fois depuis 7 ans
seul l'effectif moyen réalisé nous a été
communiquée et non le plafond
ministériel des emplois autorisés cet
oubli regrettable nous empêche de
calculer le déficit en médecin je compte
donc sur vous monsieur le ministre pour
nous le donner ainsi que le taux de
projection des équipes médicales qui
atteignait 125 % en 2021 et le taux de
projection des équipes chirurgicales qui
étaient passés quant à lui les 200%
je tire également votre attention sur
l'iniquité de traitement des personnels
du centre de transfusion sanguine des
armées et de lassitude de recherche
biomédicale des armées ajustement exclu
des mesures du Ségure de la santé donc
du bénéfice du complément de traitement
indiciaire en raison d'une rédaction
trop restrictive des décrets
d'application il est impératif du
remédier à cette situation dans les
meilleurs délais de plus quels seront
les mesures près d'urgence prévues pour
la prochaine loi de programmation
militaire pour le service de santé des
armées mais aussi pour le commissariat
central et tous les services de soutien
de nos armées et notamment le service de
l'énergie opérationnelle comment a-t-il
comment a-t-il fonctionné en 2021 avec
un coût du baril supérieur de 77% aux
hypothèses du projet de loi de finances
et le décrochage sévère de la parité de
la euro si la hausse des prix du
carburant opérationnel et durable
l'article 5 de la loi de programmation
militaire prévoit que des crédits
supplémentaires seront ouverts en
construction budgétaire pour couvrir les
volumes nécessaires à la préparation et
à l'activité opérationnelle des forces
vous savez que la Commission a voté
cette loi de programmation militaire
pouvez-vous nous dire monsieur le
ministre comment elle est appliquée dans
le cadre du PLF 2023 et quel est le
montant des crédits supplémentaires
ouverts merci
merci Madame la rapporteur merci Michel
nous allons passer au dernier programme
le 212 soutien de la politique de
défense je donne la parole à Joël
guerriot merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre par vos propos
introductifs concis vous nous laissez le
temps de poser des questions je vous en
remercie dans son discours aux armées
prononcé en juillet dernier le président
de la République a annoncé un objectif
de doublement de la réserve
opérationnelle de premier niveau vous
avez vous-même récemment souligné
publiquement la portance de cet objectif
et à cette occasion vous avez estimé que
nous réservistes ne sont pas toujours
suffisamment bien utilisés et vous avez
appelé de vos vœux une réflexion
profonde sur l'organisation de la
réserve alors que la Cour des comptes a
récemment recommandé le transfert aux
forces de sécurité intérieure de
l'opération sentinelle dont les
militaires sont pour beaucoup issus de
la réserve opérationnelle de l'armée de
Terre quelles sont à l'heure actuelle
vos axes de réflexion sur l'évolution de
la doctrine d'emploi des réservistes
militaires
en particulier monsieur le ministre
estimez-vous que les réservistes doivent
être dédiés à des tâches spécifiques
notamment sur le territoire national ou
pensez-vous qu'ils doivent pouvoir être
intégrés à l'ensemble des missions
assurées par nos forces armées merci de
votre attention
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur rapporteur
merci Joël enfin marié Arlette Carlotti
toujours sur le 212 merci monsieur le
Président enfin Monsieur le Ministre
l'exercice budgétaire 2023 correspondra
au troisième volet et ça sera le dernier
de la mise en oeuvre de la nouvelle
politique de rémunération des militaires
elle a été déployée dès 2021 alors si
cette réforme a permis d'améliorer la
lisibilité au niveau des primes puisque
vous êtes passé de 170 primes à 8 donc
avec des mieux clarifications tout de
même elle n'aura toujours pas permis une
vraie revalorisation de la rémunération
ni de nos soldats ni de nos marins ni de
nos aviateurs dans l'ensemble de nos
forces armées le Haut comité
d'évaluation de la condition militaire
que nous recevons régulièrement à
souligner et ça ça fait longtemps et il
le dit depuis très longtemps un vrai
décrochage entre le niveau de vie des
militaires et celui des fonctionnaires
civils qui ne va pas très bien non plus
et un décrochage encore plus grand à en
vert
au niveau de vie des employés dans le
secteur privé qui là aussi ne se porte
pas terriblement bien sauf que ce
décrochage est important alors que les
suggestions sont très importantes dans
l'armée alors aujourd'hui avec une
inflation qui atteint 6% en glissement
annuel nous estimons qu'il devient
vraiment essentiel essentiel de
préserver le pouvoir d'achat du
personnel le pouvoir de d'achat du
personnel des armées donc monsieur le
ministre dans ce contexte pensez-vous un
que le niveau actuel de rémunération
suffit pour assurer l'attractivité de
nos armées parce que c'est extrêmement
inquiétant y a-t-il des pistes de
réflexion que vous avez vous avez tout à
l'heure évoqué l'intégration du point
d'indice de la fonction publique il y
a-t-il des indices de réflexion des
pistes de réflexion pour la prochaine
loi de programmation militaire dans ce
domaine petite question subsidiaire vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure un groupe de
travail pour préparer la loi de
programmation militaire et vous avez
évoqué le plan de famille ça veut dire
que vous voulez le faire évoluer vous
avez déjà des idées en quel sens
merci
ma rapporteur merci Marie Arlette donc à
ce stade je vais vous donner la parole
monsieur le ministre pour répondre à ce
premier train de question à la fois
précise et concise votre précision sera
de même certainement appréciée par les
membres de la commission puis après nous
passerons aux questions de nos autres
collègues afin de favoriser l'échange et
le dialogue monsieur le ministre ou
l'équipe qui vous entoure vous pouvez
évidemment répondre comme vous le
souhaitez et regrouper les questions ou
les ou les analyser l'une après l'autre
comme vous le souhaitez merci monsieur
le Président ça m'a disposition du
Parlement bon l'inflation c'est un défi
qui s'impose à nous
quatre sur table sénateur de neige oui
je pense qu'il faut pas raconter
d'histoires on a une marche à 3
milliards et plus que bienvenue on y
revient pas et que globalement
l'estimation de l'inflation au moment où
on se parle problème de l'inflation
c'est que on en parle au moment où on se
situe c'est globalement un effet d'un
milliard
donc quelles sont les solutions que nous
avons sur la table mais c'est un
problème qui n'est pas que le problème
du gouvernement c'est aussi le problème
de tous collectivement déjà parce que
cette inflation ne concerne pas que le
ministère des armées comme acheteur
public c'est une question qu'on peut
poser à d'autres ministères qui se
ressentent leur programmation et qu'ils
ne le soit pas donc nous on a de la
chance déjà avec des crédits qui
augmentent la question se prend pas de
la même manière mais ça ne suffit pas
parce que si notre programmation existe
elle est là pour définir aussi un cadre
pour créer des effets militaires réels
quelles sont les solutions en face d'une
1 la question des carburants ça a été
rappelé par un certain nombre d'entre
vous ce qui me permet quand même
peut-être de préciser le fonctionnement
de l'article 5 de la LPM sur les besoins
de carburant des armées c'est un besoin
qui se fait en gestion je ne peux pas
vous poser enfin je ne peux pas vous
répondre sur pour 2023 combien vous
prévoyez puisque à chaque fois on prend
d'abord et on consomme d'abord les AE et
les CP en l'espèce plutôt qui sont
ouverts sur les carburants peu importe
le prix du carburant peu importe
l'activité opérationnelle enfin
attention une forme de sobriété enfin la
sobriété au combat c'est quand même tout
à fait relatif et si évidemment
l'ensemble des crédits de paiement pour
les carburants sont consommés on
déclenche l'article 5 qui permet de
venir le gouvernement devant le
Parlement l'Assemblée nationale Sénat
pour ouvrir des crédits typiquement vous
avez voté 50 millions d'euros
supplémentaires cette année pour les
carburants et pour le coup c'est bien de
l'argent en plus de la trajectoire de de
la loi de programmation militaire on le
dit jamais en disant que c'est en plus
mais c'est ça tombe sous le sens ce sont
des crédits nouveaux donc la question du
carburant elle est traitée et je forme
le vœu que cette disposition continue de
perdurer dans les prochaines lois de
programmations militaires parce que
l'idée du législateur initialement était
de se dire quand on est au combat quand
on est en OPEX évidemment il ne faut pas
créer un moment donné de rupture
d'approvisionnement en carburant et donc
on s'est débrouillé pour entre Parlement
et exécutif avoir cette mécanique qui
nous permet à chaque fois de ne pas
avoir de rupture les reports de charge
bon c'est un peu la Cigale et la Fourmi
cette affaire les report de charge déjà
on peut se permettre de vous proposer un
milliard d'euros de report de charge
parce que précisément Florence Parly est
différente équipes avaient fait
attention vous n'avait pas abusé des
reports de charge et les avait même
plutôt largement réduits et la bise fut
venue et c'est ainsi que nous nous
permettons de réaugmenter ces rapports
de remport de charge parce que des
efforts ont été faits avant faut pas
raconter n'importe quoi c'est à dire la
raison de dire que c'est une forme de
dette qu'on décale dans le temps faudra
bien le payer un moment donné la vraie
c'est à quel moment faut-il le payer
est-ce qu'on fait le pari que
l'inflation peut à un moment donné
diminuer ou est-ce qu'elle va continuer
et ça nul ne le sait donc c'est mon
troisième point pour répondre très
précisément l'inflation moi je défends
la proposition de report de charge parce
qu'elle permet de garder les effets des
3 milliards pour nos armées l'année
prochaine
néanmoins oui en fonction du rythme et
de la dynamique de cette inflation je le
Président il faudra sans doute qu'on
vous rende compte pendant l'année 2023
de là où nous en sommes c'est une
réalité je l'ai dit l'Assemblée
nationale je le dis devant vous nous
avons donc un rendez-vous sur l'analyse
de cette inflation dans l'année 2023
mais au moment où je vous demande
d'ouvrir des crédits pour les armés il
est clair que le report de charge permet
de garantir les effets à 3000 arbres
après il faudra évidemment le traiter
sur le Scaff j'y répondrai peut-être en
mutualisant les les différentes réponses
comme pour les comment dire les les
munitions bon sur la révision de la LPM
j'avais entendu au mois de juillet les
remontrances du Sénat je les entends de
nouveau aujourd'hui j'espère de bonne
foi avoir par deux fois en public et
dans une audition retransmis donner la
méthode qui était la mienne validée par
le Président de la République pour
co-construire la prochaine et le PM avec
le Parlement vous me permettrez de dire
aussi que c'est un peu ma culture par
ailleurs et puis Center Perrin m'a
invité à ne pas avoir peur du Sénat ça
tombe bien pour ça d'ailleurs que j'y
étais candidat que je me suis fait lire
sénateur je pense ne pas avoir peur du
Sénat pour cette raison mais toujours
mais je m'en réjouis mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que
non mais je c'est à la fin du bal qu'on
paye les musiciens mais je pense que
j'aime la démocratie représentative et
j'aime le Parlement voilà pas dire mieux
donc après est-ce qu'on sera d'accord
sur tout c'est une autre affaire et ça
est-ce que vous êtes tous d'accord entre
vous c'est aussi notre affaire c'est le
principe de la démocratie en tout cas
c'est un sujet suffisamment grave et
sérieux les contraintes qui s'imposent à
nous l'inflation en est une autre BITD
je vais vers un instant il y a pas de
miracle et donc je pense que c'est sain
d'avoir justement ce partage de ces
réflexions et aussi des décisions que
l'on prend parce que elles sont sur des
impacts 5 10 et parfois 30 ou 40 ans
regardons les grandes décisions que nos
anciens ont pris sur les sujets de
défense
sur monsieur serveur Perrin justement
sur les autres pays et bon disais tout à
l'heure c'est compliqué de se comparer
pour les par les l'Allemagne dissuasion
pas dissuasion nucléaire
outre-mer pas outre-mer les modèles
d'armée sont quand même très différents
moi je note quand même que
certains ont déjà annoncé des
augmentations qui vont en 2030 nous nous
n'avons pas annoncé encore les
augmentations jusqu'en 2030 puisque nous
sommes dans l'empire d'une loi que vous
avez votée avec les marches que vous
connaissez donc là aussi c'est à la fin
du bal qu'on paye les musiciens après
est-ce que la dépense fait l'efficacité
du modèle d'armée
il suffit de regarder
notre histoire pour voir que pas
toujours et donc je pense que la vraie
ça peut aider sur le volet technologique
mais je suis désolé de dire que il faut
regarder aussi le courage des
combattants faut regarder aussi la
doctrine dans le bois de César mais
des casernes bien achalandées avec des
militaires qui n'en sortent jamais ce
n'est pas la même chose qu'une armée qui
se déploie pour des missions et moi je
défends le modèle d'armée kénose j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure sur
l'attractivité quand on interroge
beaucoup de nos jeunes dans les
régiments dans les bases navales ou
aériennes ils viennent aussi parce que
non pas en effet la guerre parce que
nous sommes une armée paix et avec un
pays avec des valeurs importantes mais
c'est une armée d'emploi comme on dit si
bien et quand on parle d'entraînement
c'est pas que des milliards c'est aussi
la manière dont on l'emploi et ça les
chefs militaires sont bien mieux
qualifiés que moi pour en répondre
puisque pour avoir été général 5 étoiles
il faut avoir été souillots et
lieutenant et dans leur vie de soldats
ils peuvent dire à quel point ils ont
rencontré des gens qui venaient
justement pour chercher cette efficacité
et donc je crois que nous pourrons y
revenir sur le modèle de l'armée complet
alors vous avez dit vous avez fait un
discours par bloc bah oui parce que là
on n'est pas en train de présenter une
loi de programmation militaire avec une
vision malheureusement la lol fait pas
heureusement d'ailleurs plutôt la lol
fait passer par là donc mission
programme vous-même vous avez réparti de
la parole par rapporteur sur des
programmes et donc à un moment donné le
catéchisme budgétaire nous amène à
devoir présenter les choses de manière
scolaire et par programme donc c'est
ainsi en revanche là vous avez raison et
je rajouterais même que je rappelle qu'à
la loi de programmation militaire que
qui a été votée que vous avez votée il y
a des annexes avec des cibles
capacitaires et donc quand on arrive
avec la liste des avions etc on ne fait
aussi que répondre aussi aux objectifs
que législateur a fixé dans la loi donc
vous ne pouvez pas me le reprocher par
ailleurs néanmoins là vous avez raison
c'est que pour la LPM il faudra se
détacher de ces blocs il faudra parler
vision à quoi ressemble l'armée
française en 2030 à quoi on ne voudrait
pas qu'elle ressemble que faut-il faire
peut-être tout seul à tout prix parce
que sur certains sujets de souveraineté
il est impensable de faire autrement
quels sont les sujets au travers de nos
alliances que nous souhaitons faire
autrement ça évidemment ça sera l'objet
de LP mais ce n'est pas que ma vision
puisque je vous ai dit on partagera
cette vision dès la rencontre sur la RNS
parce que c'est aussi enfin dis-moi ton
danger je te donnerai ton armée malgré
tout le monde dans lequel nous nous
trouvons nous obligera aussi à repartir
des menaces pour donner évidemment ce
que ça veut dire après oui notre modèle
d'armée est complet et puisque vous
m'avez invité à nous comparer je note
que des grands voisins de pays parfois
non loin de nous séparés par un bras de
mer ont parfois décidé d'arrêter un
certain nombre de fonctionnalités de
leur armée faisant un pari que si besoin
en été pourrait réactiver ce besoin là
et que je le dis avec bienveillance sans
esprit polémique avec cet allié et ce
voisin et cet ami
que oui la Grande-Bretagne a du mal à
regénérer certaines capacités et on l'a
vu notamment dans la guerre du Golfe
avec leur armée de terre donc gardez un
modèle d'armée complet n'est pas une fin
en soi mais elle garantit aussi quelque
chose mais on aura l'occasion de dire et
la copie que nous vous proposons en tout
cas pour ces crédits pour l'année 2023
ne vient pas abîmer bien au contraire de
l'armée complet au contraire cohérence
durcissement mais le schéma pour y
revenir parce que c'est évidemment lui
qui a proposé cette vision stratégique
au pouvoir politique et évidemment nous
lançons complètement parce que elle est
pleine de bon sens et elle fait au fond
ce pivot au regard aussi de ce que nous
vivons dissolution du pack de Varsovie
années 90 année 2000 terrorisme
militarisé et là de nouveau on a quand
même édu terrorisme militarisé parce que
plus personne ne parle du terrorisme en
Afrique enfin c'est quand même une
actualité douloureuse et difficile pour
nos alliés et amis africains et que de
l'autre côté on a cette menace désormais
sur le flanc oriental de l'Europe plus
les menaces hybrides plus d'éventuelles
menaces d'une autre nature sur nos
outre-mer de là où je viens je peux vous
en parler et donc tout ça donne aussi la
projection de ce à quoi doit ressembler
notre armée de main mais on aura
l'occasion évidemment d'y revenir les
munitions oui elles sont pour la France
à l'exception peut-être de ce que le
président de la République pourrait
donner à un allié et un ami qui
s'appelle l'Ukraine puisque nous l'avons
déjà fait évidemment à l'exception de
cela il va sans dire que nous nous
dotons de munitions pour notre propre
pays et que la seule exception c'est
évidemment ce que nous pouvons donner
aux Ukrainiens mais on pose la question
est-ce que les munitions sont bien que
pour la France on m'avait posé cette
question pardon
en destination que pour la France
fabriquée en France oui avec la question
je reviendrai à la question du sénateur
à l'Isère sur la relocalisation est-ce
que l'économie de guerre fonctionne ça
dépend des entreprises carte sur table
pas de langue de bois certains
entreprises comprennent et reçoivent
fort éclair le message il fallait 24
mois pour Nexter voire plus pour
construire un canon César les
discussions que nous avons actuellement
peuvent nous amener à penser que un lot
de César pourrait être désormais être
fait en 12 mois ça c'est un effort
significatif vive labellité des
Françaises elle est capable aussi de
cette résilience après il est clair que
c'est un travail de profondeur le DGA
pour le coup là pour y revenir qui
permet de donner de la visibilité cette
visibilité ça veut pas dire que c'est le
contribuable qui paye les stocks pour
être clair et ça c'est pas l'Ukraine
c'est le covid qui vient aussi nous
rappeler qu'à un moment donné certaines
dépendances sont impensables et ça pour
le coup il faut revenir aussi sur
certains types de munitions sur certains
types d'équipements à quelque chose de
plus chimiquement pur là aussi c'est une
vision un peu gaulienne peut-être de
l'industrie de défense mais nous devons
la défendre et ça peut-être que parfois
faudra accompagner peut-être parfois
pardon de le dire faudra être aussi
ferme en tant que état client et la
fermeté ne veut pas dire qu'on est
malveillant vis-à-vis de nos entreprises
mais je compte sur le Sénat justement
aussi pour trouver le bon ton qu'il faut
avoir avec notre industrie qui fait
notre fierté et dont on salue les
équipes parce que leur engagement est
complet
alors vous avez votre vision monsieur
ministre quel est-elle bon je pense
avoir répondu déjà avec les quelques
points que je viens que je viens de vous
donner madame la ministre
les coûts des OPEX merci de cette
question parce qu'elle est elle est clé
même la miss Conway bon déjà vous avez
toujours une provision qui n'existait
pas toujours dans le passé d'un virgule
deux milliards d'euros par an la
provision ça veut dire ce que ça veut
dire si c'est en dessous c'est que ça
fonctionne si c'est au-dessus il faut
trouver une autre solution quand on est
au dessus l'autre solution reste la
solidarité interministérielle qui je le
dis est un bon principe
c'est la loi et c'est un bon principe
loi voté parce que il y a quelque chose
de différent à défendre le pays et être
engagé en OPEX et que même principe que
pour les carburants on ne doit pas être
freiné dans la capacité a et puis
dernier point mais ça on le sait au
Parlement et le covid malheureusement
est venu nous amener beaucoup de loi de
finances rectificatives pour les raisons
que vous connaissez la gestion et la
capacité évidemment en conduite de
modifier les choses pour la question
madame la ministre sur
2022 je ne peux pas encore répondre à
votre question mais il est clair que les
crédits vont être importants et votre
est important pour deux raisons déjà la
manœuvre entre le Mali et le Niger est
une manœuvre qui en tant que telle a été
une grande réussite logistique menée par
les armées en sécurité en conduite mais
ça a nécessité évidemment quelques
moyens et qu'évidemment être au Niger
est aussi une forme de projection d'une
autre nature que barkham ça va sans dire
mais enfin est une projection qui est
quand même fixe des moyens et puis bien
sûr les moyens de réassurance sur le
flanc s de l'OTAN ça malheureusement
lorsque vous avez voté les crédits de
l'année dernière nous ne pouvions pas
savoir que Vladimir Poutine envahirait
l'Ukraine au mois de février et qu'il
nous faudrait déployer des dispositifs
de nature nationale pardonnez-moi en
Roumanie
participer à la police ou à la défense
du ciel dans les pays Polona baltes bref
donc il est évident que là il y a une
facture globalement Roumanie Estonie
Pologne Lituanie désormais au moment où
je vous parle on est quand même déjà
quelque chose qui peut chiffrer autour
de 600 à 700 millions d'euros bon tout
ça coûte cher le carburant coûte cher
déployé des avions de chasse coûte cher
il faut aussi qu'on en fasse la
pédagogie auprès de nos de nos
concitoyens construire un camp un chinku
dans de bonnes conditions coûte
nécessairement un peu d'argent donc tout
ça faudra aussi qu'on l'assume et donner
de plus en plus aussi le prix de ce que
nous faisons
participent aussi à l'acceptabilité
sociétale de ce qui est fait en tout cas
je pense qu'il faut faire 4 sur table
pour reprendre l'expression du sénateur
de l'âge donc pour des OPEX voilà ce
qu'il en est pour les carburants mamie
je vous ai répondu où et l'argent de
l'article 5 pour l'année en cours c'est
fait 50 millions d'euros pour l'année
prochaine nous verrons bien aussi en
fonction de l'évolution des coûts fond
spécial Ukraine nous vous le proposerons
par voie d'amendement soit en lot de
finance ou référence rectificatif
puisque entre le moment où le projet de
loi de finance était présenté au Conseil
des ministres l'édition des Bleus
budgétaires et l'annonce du président de
la République consécutive aux
discussions qu'il a eu avec le président
zellinski évidemment entre temps les
calendriers sont les calendriers de la
guerre en Ukraine ne sont pas nos
calendrier budgétaires et donc
évidemment le Parlement aura à le
valider cela va sans dire je précise que
je signérais la convention des portes en
création de ce fond avec le ministre de
la Défense
ukrainien ce jeudi en marge de la
ministériale de l'OTAN c'est un fond de
100 millions d'euros et deux premières
commandes de 2 x 5 millions d'euros sont
déjà engagés ça me permet aussi de
rendre compte au Parlement de cette
affaire pour les rythmes des livraisons
des rafales question que vous m'aviez
déjà posé madame la ministre au mois de
juillet dernier peut-être vous préciser
que les rafales d'occasion cédaient la
Grèce ont déjà été commandés comme je
l'indiqué tout à l'heure et ils seront
livrés ce que je ne vous ai pas indiqué
tout à l'heure avant la fin de cette loi
de programmation militaire et que les
rafales d'occasion CD à la Croatie était
12 seront commandés Madame le Ministre
en 2023 et donc là aussi livré avant la
fin de la prochaine et le PM et j'avais
indiqué au mois de juillet devant vous
et je le redis de nouveau devant vous et
je l'ai dit à nos amis de Dassault et
que désormais je ne souhaite plus que
l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace
constitue le tampon sur les différents
exports et nous sommes heureux des
exports de Rafale mais qu'évidemment on
doit aussi garantir l'intégrité de nos
moyens je regarde le chef d'état-major
de l'armée de verre qui lui-même très
vigilant et donc je fais un heureux en
le rappelant devant vous monsieur le
sénateur à Lisa sur le renseignement
rassurez-vous les si les crédits de
paiement diminuent quelque peu les aveux
pardon diminue quelque peu c'est tout
simplement parce que ça correspond au
siège de or les a eux ont déjà été
ouvert l'année dernière enfin cette
année pour être précis 2022 les aveux
sont là et on va commencer à avoir des
crédits de paiement sur le siège de la
DGSE qui globalement une opération
tourne 900 millions d'euros même un peu
plus en fonction de comment on calcule
et donc vous allez voir désormais les AE
diminuer vous allez voir les CP
augmenter donc pas d'effet sur la
politique de renseignement en tant que
tel on est sur un programme bâtimentaire
avec les effets classiques entre eux et
CP sur le SCAF vous m'avez cité je vous
en remercie donc je vous récite ma
citation il est attendu par Paris que
cela se fera
en fait ça me permet de clarifier cette
phrase devant vous oui il y aura un
avion du futur
non mais je commence par le début enfin
oui pour les experts
mais oui il y aura un successeur au
Rafale non mais je veux démarrer par là
et je l'ai dit à mon homologue allemand
oui il y aura un succès sur du Rafale
qui a vocation a participé à la
dissuasion nucléaire aux forzaïne
stratégiques oui un successe il y aura
un successeur au Rafale qui aura
vocation à participer ne politique
d'export pour donner deux
exemples précis de votre question
sous-jacente et que donc bah oui il y a
une vision française et que comme on dit
en droit civile il faut que ces
coopérations soient signalagmatique
c'est à dire qu'il faut que les deux
parties trouvent leur compte comment on
dit en droit civil et donc j'ai rappelé
évidemment aux Allemands que et
d'ailleurs il y a les Espagnols qu'on
oublie trop souvent dans le SCAF donc il
faut nous pardonner de les oublier parce
que ils sont engagés
que évidemment le SCAF doit se faire
parce que nous avons besoin d'un avion
succession du Rafale que nous avons
besoin d'un système de Cloud
collaboratif avec l'environnement de
l'avion et que nous avons aussi besoin
d'une réflexion avec les drones autour
de cette avion donc sur la nécessité que
le programme se fasse quoi qu'il
advienne
c'est une réalité qu'il faut pour le
coup que l'on clarifie tous dans notre
position publique la coopération n'est
pas le besoin de l'avion non mais je
voilà en disant ça d'ailleurs je pense
vous avoir largement répondu et donc
cela a été dit évidemment nos
partenaires allemands parce que nous
avons besoin de cette succession
il y aura il y a un plan B alors
la réalité
mais la réalité c'est que la France n'a
pas à rougir de son savoir-faire
ça veut dire que moi je crois en cette
coopération je l'ai dit à la ministre
j'ai dit que je croyais à l'export j'ai
dit que je croyais la dissuasion
nucléaire et l'utilité cet avion pour
les forces arènes stratégiques il me
semble deux éléments structurants du
programme quand on le dit comme ça
qu'après les programmes soient
compliqués
TELUS de Vernon une culture fusée à rien
bien bien solide donc que tout ça puisse
prendre du temps que parfois il y a des
moments qui soient plus difficiles que
d'autres il faut qu'on l'accepte les
Grands Anciens aussi l'ont accepté
devant nous bon le sei était signé le
SEO W devrait l'être prochainement la
réalité c'est le contenu de la phase
avait est utile quoi qu'il arrive après
il est clair que on aura des rendez-vous
voilà je vous le dis je partage pas la
vie de certaines formations politiques
peu représenter au Sénat pour être clair
qui consisterait à dénoncer le SCAF à
priori je trouve que là ça ne nous
correspond pas à nous Français dans
notre culture précisément quelque soit
nos opinions politiques en revanche que
dans une coopération il faut qu'on soit
très engagé très engageant et qu'on dise
clairement ce qu'on veut et qu'on essaie
de la faire avancer avec nos industriels
respectifs oui ce qui vaut pour le SCAF
vaut pour le chat voilà pour être
complet pour la question que vous m'avez
pas posée sur le charme j'accélère
peut-être monsieur le Président mais PME
allez la famille PME relocalisation
pour une filière de munitions petit
calibre il faut préciser toujours petit
Kelly vous l'avez fait je vous en
remercie parce que souvent donne
l'impression qu'il y a plus de fabrique
de munitions en France non on va dire ça
un externe BDA c'est pas vrai néanmoins
effectivement sur les petits calibres
c'est pas tant l'Ukraine c'est le covid
qui nous rappelle qu'à un moment donné
on doit avoir certaines productions en
souveraineté ça fait partie de la
feuille de route du DGA de définir aussi
dans cette économie de guerre là où nous
n'acceptons plus qu'il y ait des
fragilités sur les stocks des fragilités
sous les sous-traitances ou des
fragilités sur aussi des outils de
production on rentre dans un univers
dans lequel parler de nouveau de
sabotage n'est pas quelque chose de
complètement aberrant quand vous avez
parfois des chaînes de production qui
peuvent reposer que sur un seul robot ou
sur un seul appareil ça ne correspond
pas à ce qu'un pays comme une autre peut
attendre en économie de guerre donc en
fait la galaxie l'économie de guerre
elle est globale et pour revenir sur ce
que disait nature Perrin c'est un combat
qui n'est pas d'un coup d'un soir c'est
forcément aussi un chantier qui
correspond globalement à un chantier
qu'il faudra adosser notre programmation
militaire et le schéma pourra revenir
aussi sur ce qu'il attend lui avec les
différents thèmes de la BITD parce qu'à
un moment donné le modèle technologique
industriel il est imbriqué aussi dans
notre modèle d'armée et il faut qu'on
embarque aussi la BTD mais comme une
fois de plus l'égoliste globalement ou
les communistes ailleurs aussi après
guerre notamment sur la Quatrième
République on cherchait justement cette
souveraineté française en essayant
d'être pas complètement aligné sur
Moscou pour les uns et pas complètement
aligné sur Washington pour les autres
voilà c'est quand même ça aussi histoire
française il faut essayer évidemment de
continuer à la faire vivre monsieur le
sénateur legranar sur alors je vous
rassure les chiffres ils sont sortis
dans la presse de Bercy c'est pas pour
réconcilier tout le monde mais de Bercy
de l'EMA et cetera sont des chiffres qui
sont faux voilà donc je peux pas vous
dire mieux parce que précisément on part
pas de la courbe on essaie de repartir
des effets militaires réels ce qui est
d'ailleurs plus compliqué faut dire que
jadis sont reparti de la courbe parce
qu'elle diminuait pas s'appelait le
rabot par le haut RGPP là désormais la
première LPM a déjà traduit des
augmentations de crédit plus besoin de
faire cette démonstration
sincérité le vrai sujet c'est quel est
le modèle l'armée que l'on veut avoir et
on revient sur ce qu'on s'est dit tout à
l'heure et donc après évidemment il faut
regarder la courbe que ça donnera mais
ça évidemment ça appartient au président
de la République de de le dire donc je
vous rassure de spéculons pas sur les
chiffres et d'ailleurs je ne peux pas
proposer au Sénat je ne peux pas
proposer au Sénat de co-construire c'est
le programmation militaire si un chiffre
était déjà arrêté ou alors je vous
donnerai une cible et dans cette cible
nous travaillons tous ensemble
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de cible arrêté
en somme ou en courbe allez grand scoop
si ce n'est comme je vous le disais
qu'on va pas commencer à diminuer des
moyens qu'on a nous-mêmes augmenté donc
le sujet donc la pente de cette
croissance c'est déjà pas si mal pour
construire notre programmation militaire
oui
pardonnez-moi monsieur le sénateur à
Lisa excellent d'un seul mot ils font
des choses qui nous intéressent très
directement souveraineté au-delà de
l'intérêt industriel de là où je me
place je vais plutôt parler de la nature
stratégique de ce qu'ils font
2 il existe une disposition dite
Montebourg qui permet à l'état de
s'immiscer dans une transaction si nous
estimons que trois les équipes de la DGA
et du mineur mon cabinet pour être clair
en lien avec Bercy sont en train de
faire des tours de table pour ne pas
être agressif vis-à-vis du vendeur ou
d'un éventuel acheteur mais dire que
nous sommes bel et bien là et que oui il
y a quelques intérêts de souveraineté
sur ce que fait Xia voilà je peux pas et
je peux pas vous en dire plus à l'heure
où je vous parle mais j'ai bon espoir
aller dans les quelques semaines qui
viennent en tout cas avant la fin de
l'année 2022 d'être plus disait et plus
précis sur excellent partez moi j'avais
oublié
cyber DGSE oui on continue d'augmenter
monsieur le sénateur
le déménagement et le nouveau siège
n'est pas qu'un changement bâtimentaire
ça s'accompagne aussi d'une
réorganisation profonde j'ai signé les
arrêtés de réorganisation de la DGSE que
Bernard araignée m'avait proposé au
début de mon arrivée à Brienne donc au
mois de juin
on a fêté d'ailleurs les 40 ans de la
DGSE ce matin dans la cour des abeilles
le président Cambon représentait le
Sénat bon déjà c'est une c'est une boîte
comme on dit dont l'identité militaire
alors que les militaires n'y sont pas
majoritaires et clés je le dis parce que
on a besoin de cette identité c'est une
originalité que le général de Gaulle a
souhaité avec le BCRA donc nous avons un
héritage là aussi évidemment à défendre
que la réforme qu'a voulu Bernard Rémy
et que nous avons évidemment validé
permet de s'adapter aux nouvelles
menaces et aux nouvelles géographies de
ces menaces
prudent ce que je dis et puis que
évidemment là où se posera la question
pour la prochaine et le PM c'est quels
sont les moyens nouveaux qu'il faut
donner à la DGSE et notamment aussi sur
le volet cyber et sur la direction
technique sur lequel là aussi bah il
faut qu'on avance
aussi les nouvelles clés de demain les
agents du
BCRA ont réussi jadis à craquer les
codes de la machine énigma demain est-ce
que nous serons capables de faire la
même chose sur le quantique voilà ça ça
renvoie aussi à la réflexion sur la LPM
mais c'est clair en tout cas il est pas
question de déshabiller ou des abîmer
évidemment la DGSE quand comparaison
avec les Britanniques et les Allemands
c'est pas très diplomatique de poser
cette question en tout cas ma réponse
pourrait ne pas l'être
on n'a pas rougir de ce qu'on fait
nous sur une audition ouverte et
retransmise en dire plus dans un format
que le président Cambon pourrait adapter
sur les questions de renseignement
évidemment pour y revenir on a vraiment
pas à rougir de ce qui est fait monsieur
le sénateur sigoletti
MC ou est-ce que c'est suffisant
bon bah c'est la même chose quand ça
augmente c'est toujours plus suffisant
que lorsque ça diminue je pense que
c'est le séma qui peut répondre avec les
CM l'effort en tout cas qui a été fait
je prends témoigner et vraiment faut
rendre ça aux armées parce que c'est un
travail qui est délicat c'est de mettre
le paquet sur les urgences tant que les
crédits que nous vous demandons pour 23
sont des crédits qui vont directement à
aller se brancher dans les endroits je
vous ai donné l'exemple d'aéronautique
tout à l'heure c'est un exemple clé les
munitions sont une autre forme c'est pas
de la maintenance c'est pas du MCO enfin
c'est la même chose et pour le coup pour
les munitions là aussi ça s'accompagne
je sais que vous suivez de près cette
question ça s'accompagne aussi du
renfort qui était prévu dans la
programmation militaire des différentes
équipes qui suivent évidemment les OPEX
j'ai répondu tout à l'heure je n'y
reviens pas madame la sénatrice Gréau
merci de votre fidélité au SSA alors
déficit de médecins et taux de
projection médicale je ne les ai pas
avec moi mais je voulais dois donc je
vais demander à mes équipes et je
voulais transmettrai ainsi commandes de
la commission qui serait évidemment
intéressé bon et c'est ça je vous redis
ce que je vous ai dit en juillet pour
moi c'est clé on peut pas dire qu'on
durcit qu'on fait cohérent si le service
qui s'assure de ce soutien
extraordinairement central et vital ne
suit pas c'est un service qui a parfois
été abîmé dans le passé faut pas se
raconter d'histoires c'est un service
qui a été sur sollicité encore récemment
y compris par votre serviteur comme mise
les outre-mer ou on doit au SSA une
grande partie de la résilience du
système de soins dans les territoires
d'outre-mer pour les raisons que vous
connaissez sur lequel j'en reviens pas
que si des soldats ont parlé d'armée
d'emploi accepte de prendre des risques
sur le terrain c'est parce qu'ils savent
aussi que tout sera mis en oeuvre pour
les secourir et que leur famille sont
savent très bien pertinemment que le
meilleur des soins leur sera accordé
donc dans le contrat opération le
service de santé des armées est dedans
c'est pas un à côté ça veut dire que
après je sais pas quels sont vos désirs
sur la coproduction et programmation
militaire à venir sur le service de
santé des armées pour moi il faut une
copie complètement nouvelle sur le SSA à
mon avis avec un bon spectaculaire sur
la réserve qui nous permet aussi en
fonction du niveau d'intensité auquel
nous sommes confrontés on a
malheureusement le droit d'avoir
plusieurs ennuis en même temps on peut
avoir une pandémie covid en même temps
qu'un attentat de masse qui pourrait
saturer déjà au persil et en même temps
un besoin opérationnel lepex
donc globalement on peut se dire que ces
choses là malheureusement peuvent
arriver les
et les autres en même temps et
typiquement être en capacité d'avoir un
une réponse avec des réservices etc est
un sujet clé en tout cas je le renvoie
pour l'année 2023 on sera 289 millions
d'euros pour le SSA là où nous étions à
282 millions d'euros donc ce sont des
crédits qui augmentent de quelques
millions d'euros ce qui est quand même
significatif enfin Monsieur deux
dernières interventions je serai plus
rapide pour la prochaine save pardon
monsieur la ceinture guerriot sur la
réserve
on le renvoie au groupe peut-être de
travail qu'on va constituer dans un dans
quelques instants avec le Sénat il est
clair qu'on peut pas parler de haute
intensité si un moment donné on n'a pas
un modèle beaucoup plus cohérent avec
nos réserves c'est-à-dire en clair que
ceux qui sont déjà réservistes et quand
un ESR soient vraiment convoqué et
utilisé à bon escient parce que vous
lutter contre l'attrition on dit il faut
doubler la réserve mais au moins la
doubler c'est déjà que les gens la
quittent plus ou la quittent pas et ça
c'est très inégal parce que ça va comme
séminer ça dépend des personnalités ça
dépend des régiments des unités parfois
de la personnalité même du chef du
régiment ça réserviste en gendarmerie
qui vous parle d'un groupement
gendarmerie à l'autre la mère de vivre
la réserve n'était pas la même bon
ça pose aussi des questions sur la
doctrine même politique de la réserve
est-ce que c'est un devoir qu'un citoyen
a lorsqu'il a signé un ESR ou est-ce
qu'on développe un droit pour chaque
citoyen de ce pays de participer à la
défense du pays
si c'est un droit ça veut dire limite
d'âge ou les conditions physiques
doivent à mon avis être vues en
profondeur aujourd'hui nous refusons des
personnes qui sont atteintes d'obésité
pardon cette expression qui sont
candidats pour être réservistes ou comme
si Bert parce qu'on applique les règles
alors et même pour deux cas ou trois cas
on doit changer les règles sont des
sites que c'est un droit de participer à
la défense de son pays j'en dis pas plus
mais ça donne un peu la tonalité et
l'ambition de ce que l'on peut faire
mais le schéma beaucoup de ces maths
aussi ont travaillé et logique aussi
territorialisée de la réserve et
département des unités militaires il y a
des départements qui sont devenus des
déserts militaires comme on dit si bien
donc la réserve peut tout aussi un moyen
de faire le trait d'union au mieux de
tout ça mais j'aurai l'occasion de y
revenir en ouvrant au groupe de travail
madame Carlotti merci pour vos questions
nprm
il y a plusieurs approches c'est vrai
que la nprm
c'est c'est de l'indemnité si j'ose dire
et pas de l'indicien mais ça vous avez
raison de revenir sur le pouvoir d'achat
ou sur l'attractivité mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'on reçoit de nouveau très
pédagogue c'est une rationalisation une
simplification et une hausse du régime
indemnitaire ça c'est très clair c'est
500 millions d'euros quand même sur la
marche qui est là on est autour de 400
c'est quelque chose de puissant après il
y a la question globale indiciaire qui
n'est pas la question indemnitaire je
pense quand même qu'il faut qu'on l'a on
l'a dit ceci bon l'attractivité au sein
de l'armée je renvoie ça au sein et au
Sénat je suis pas certain que la
question
indemnitaire ou en tout cas indiciaire
soit central dans l'attractivité en tout
cas ça dépend des endroits il est clair
que sur les métiers nouveaux cyber là
oui et un enjeu de fidélisation qui est
clair et vous avez raison de le pointer
après quand on va dans des unités de
combat force spéciale et autres
j'entends rarement parler de ça sur
d'autres sujets donc je pense qu'il faut
le regarder aussi par par unité ou par
famille de combattants ou parfois des
choses sont un tout petit peu
distinguées et enfin plan famille groupe
de travail oui j'ai un certain nombre
d'idées je l'ai un peu dit tout à
l'heure notamment sur la manière dont on
peut associer les collectivités
territoriales on a trop de sujets pour
faire vite encore sur les rentrées
scolaires les familles avec des enfants
et là je le vois il y a un sujet avec
les maires ou les présentes départements
pour les collèges ou les présents de
région pour les lycées ou parfois facile
un ministère qui connaît le plus de
mutations dans la République
pratiquement et là je pense qu'on peut
largement fluidifier encore les choses
en matière d'accueil des familles c'est
un exemple très précis et c'est une
chose c'est l'hébergement je vous
parlais du lien aussi avec les
collectivités territoriales moi je le
vois dans l'Eure on n'a jamais mis à
contribution le grand bailleur sous
contrôle de Nicole Duranton n'a jamais
mis à contribution le grand bailleur de
l'Eure pour l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace pour la base aérienne donc ça
veut bien dire qu'on a encore des tuyaux
civils qu'on peut brancher sur Youtube
militaire et après avoir comme on
accompagne que les victimiser pour se
faire pardon j'ai été long je sais pas
si le séma souhaite compléter sur des
points durs ou le DGA sur l'économie de
guerre si vous le voulez bien on va tout
de suite embrayer sur les questions
minute qui pourraient être un peu plus
courte dans son pas moins
précises et après comme ça l'ensemble
des de l'équipe du ministère pourra
répondre si vous le souhaitez Olivier
Cadic on lui demande à chacun évidemment
de compresser un peu penser monsieur le
ministre la Chine cherche à utiliser sa
domination technologique à des fins de
surveillance un média annonce que le
chef de l'agence britannique de
renseignement appelle aujourd'hui les
pays occidentaux agir en urgence pour
contrer cette énorme menace le SGDSN
recensait ici 9 attaques d'espionnage
cette année venant de hackers utilisant
la langue chinoise est-ce que les
nouveaux moyens humains annoncés pour la
guerre hybride sont susceptibles de
répondre à cette alerte britannique
l'arme laser au cœur de la lutte
antidrone est une mission prioritaire
pour nos armées la France semble avoir
pris en retard dans le domaine c'est
donc aujourd'hui un enjeu clé pour notre
BITD et sa souveraineté la société Sila
c'est au centre du débat l'an dernier
arriva avant du sépare minoritaire dans
la Silas à lumibird fleuron européen des
technologies laser qui équipe entre
autres le Rafale et le laser mégajoul du
CEA si là c'est aujourd'hui dans une
situation financière catastrophique
doublée d'une dépendance technologique
grave vis-à-vis des États-Unis auprès
desquels elle s'approvisionne en source
laser alors que l'uniburn est un des
rares acteurs au plan mondial à
maîtriser industriellement cette
technologie de la vie de tous seuls
l'univers est à même de retourner cette
situation désastreuse et faire gagner
délai budget et indépendance pour nos
forces armées le montage industriel
envisagé précédemment qui ignore
l'unibird a conduit un impasse actuel
qui dure depuis 14 mois d'inaction des
alternatives impliquant lumbird existe
et ne demande qu'à être activée monsieur
le ministre allez-vous prendre
rapidement les mesures qui s'imposent
pour en sortir et reconnaître aux ETI
pépites leur rôle essentiel dans la
préservation de notre souveraineté merci
Olivier Isabelle Raymond pavéro monsieur
le ministre la guerre en Ukraine a
accentué les intensité des stratégies
hybrides de manipulation de la formation
mise en œuvre dans l'espace notamment
méditerranéen par des puissances
hostiles à la présence européenne
notamment dans les Balkans et en Afrique
du Nord quelle mesure
envisagez-vous pour accélérer le
déploiement de moyens de lutte contre la
désinformation sachant que la boussole
stratégique qui se retrouve dans le
budget intègre-t-elle aujourd'hui
suffisamment de mécanismes qui
permettent d'éviter que l'Union
européenne perdent la bataille des
récits en Méditerranée merci
merci Isabelle François Patriat
président de la parole
président au-delà de ce budget
historique que vous avez évoqué que nous
saluons une ministre vous avez évoqué la
réassurance sur le flanc oriental par la
France dans le cadre de l'OTAN avec son
rôle de nations cadre Roumanie
vous savez que depuis deux jours des
bombardements ont eu lieu partout sur le
territoire ukrainien et pour les
présidents multiplie ces demandes de
matériel militaire et de formation de
soldats alors où la démocratie n'est
plus contestérée comme un régime
incontestable et où notre liberté n'est
plus acquise pour reprendre la formule
prendre la République notre soutien
militaire à l'Ukraine est plus que
jamais nécessaire pouvez-vous nous dire
en quelques mots vous l'avez appelé tout
à l'heure quels sont sur les trois
grands chapitres d'aide à l'Ukraine qui
existe déjà et peut-être nous dire
quelle est le nouvel agenda
d'accompagnement militaire de l'Ukraine
dans les semaines à venir
merci Président je constate avec bonheur
que vos annonces du début de la séance
font déjà les grands titres de la presse
donc vous voyez que le Sénat sert à
quelque chose et que vous n'êtes pas
venu pour rien
nous sommes au Sénat devant la
commission
Nicole Duranton
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez déjà répondu donc à
deux de mes questions concernant le plan
familier les réservistes et vous nous
avez annoncé que des groupes de travail
vont être créés donc le rendez-vous est
pris donc j'ai une troisième question en
mars 2021 l'Union européenne a mis en
place la facilité européenne donc pour
la paix donc l'Union européenne est
désormais dotée d'un nouvel instrument
bien sûr financier qui couvrent toutes
ces actions extérieures ayant des
implications militaires dans le domaine
de la défense bien sûr donc le fond
budgétaire est d'une valeur
approximative de 5 milliards d'euros
pour la période 2021 2027 qui est
financé bien sûr par les contributions
des États membres de l'Union européenne
donc la facilité européenne a servi donc
concrètement dans le contexte de la
guerre en Ukraine donc la France
participe à quelle hauteur et
pensez-vous que dans l'état donc de
l'évolution du conflit que celle-ci
devra être rapidement réhaussée je vous
remercie
merci Nicole Guillaume Gontard Président
vous avez la parole oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre votre
prédécesseur a engagé un processus de
verdissement nos armées qui étaient
absolument indispensables tant en terme
de coût 860 millions d'euros avant la
crise énergétique et sans doute sans
doute proche du milliard depuis que de
consommation unités à water la défense
est le plus gros poste énergétique de
l'État et en cette période de crise
énergétique structurelle et alors que
l'inflation vient d'être très largement
encaissés augmentation de crédit de 3
milliards prévus par la LPM il est de
plus en plus indispensable tant de point
de vue écologiques économique de
renforcer l'effort de sobriété de nos
armées alors d'abord sur le sur le bâti
et vous la râpez c'est aussi le confort
des militaires et des familles le
ministère prévoit le remplacement de
1600 chaudière charbon et fioul d'ici
2031 l'effort de pour 2023 portera sur
150 chaudière pour quelques 10 millions
d'euros cet effort n'est pas plus rapide
que celui qui est demandé aux Françaises
et français et donc il me semble que du
coup aussi dans la défense on doit
pouvoir être exemplaire et notamment sur
la question de rénovation globale du des
bâtiments et puis sur la question des
transports qui est le principal poste de
consommation énergétique vous l'avez
d'ailleurs rappelé les efforts restent
légers d'ici la fin de l'année 2023 on
aura atteint 25 % du parc de véhicule
administratif équipé de véhicules à
faible émission et le ministère évoque
1% de carburant dans les avions on est
encore de l'ordre du du symbole donc
est-ce que
vous voulez connaître un petit peu les
orientations et les réflexions
existantes en matière de réduction de
consommation et que ça soit en matière
de logistique de déplacement ou de
développement de nouveaux équipements
merci
merci président andriol merci Président
je souhaiterais rebondir monsieur le
ministre sur la loi de programmation
militaire que vous avez évoqué dans vos
propos liminaires il y a plusieurs
reprises armée dernier la Cour des
comptes a formulé plusieurs
commandements concernant cette loi de
programmation militaire et le rapport de
la rue Cambon inquiet des conséquences
que pourrait avoir les dégradations des
finances publiques sur la poursuite des
efforts de défense préconise notamment
alors je cite d'exploiter davantage les
synergies les opportunités européennes
en particulier dans le domaine de
l'armement si l'avantage en termes de
partage des coûts de développement et de
consolidation de l'industrie défense est
évident il s'agit aussi tout simplement
de conforter l'autonomie stratégique
européenne devenue encore plus
impérative dans le contexte de la crise
ukrainienne
quelles leçons peut-on tirer de
l'expérience du SCAF puisque SCAF il y
aura et quelles sont de façon plus
générale comme pouvez-vous tracer les
perspectives en matière de coopération
européenne
merci André enfin à la Cazabon merci
ma question est d'autant plus courte
qu'elle nécessitait pas une réponse
urgente mais je suis parti d'une phrase
du ministre c'est là qui a dit les
dépenses assurent-elles l'efficacité
d'une armée et ça j'ai essayé de mémoire
de me souvenir des budgets militaires
États-Unis 700 milliards la Chine 200 la
Russie 110 et l'Europe rassemblée 560
16700 on peut se dire on est la deuxième
puissance militaire au monde dans une
réflexion est-ce qu'il y a eu déjà des
études où est-ce qu'il faudrait des
comparaisons pour voir l'efficacité
d'une armée
mais on doit se poser la question
pourquoi le repas est 560 milliards de
budget militaires rassemblés n'a rien à
voir en comparaison avec des 700
milliards des États-Unis
on a la nuit pour répondre
[Rires]
monsieur le ministre voilà le deuxième
train de question
un peu question courte réponse courte
merci je termine par la fin si vous me
autorisez avec le sénateur casabone
évidemment plus il y a de l'argent plus
ça donne des capacités à faire mais la
notion d'efficacité ça sera le cœur de
nos réflexions et les notion
d'efficacité défense du territoire
intérêt vitaux quid dissuasion
efficacité force spéciale culture des
forces spéciales de chaque pays capacité
à prendre des risques amener des
opérations discrètes on n'a pas tous la
même culture et plus d'ailleurs les
armées sont vieilles parfois plus elles
ont elles ont ce savoir faire là
efficacité c'est quoi c'est la qualité
des états majeurs la capacité à avoir
des académies militaires qui font qu'on
a des têtes bien bien pleines bien
formés on a parlé de la BITD la BITD
fait partie de l'efficacité quid
pardon de le dire mais la capacité à
viser juste
non mais la masse parfois fait la
différence c'est sûr que plus on tape
plus on finit par toucher les objectifs
parfois dans une forme de sobriété on a
aussi l'exigence bref donc en fait la
notion d'efficacité ça sera un mot clé
dans la prochaine LPM parce que sinon ce
sera la génération de parlementaire et
de ministre dont on dira ils sont sympas
ils ont ouvert des crédits plusieurs
milliards d'euros mais à quoi a servi
cette armée avec plus d'argent donc ça
il faudra y répondre j'ai plein d'idées
et plein de propositions à faire mais
c'est forcément quelque chose qui doit
se faire de manière aussi collective
donc ça on y reviendra peut-être que sur
Silas le délégué généralement si les 16
heures qui a dit qu'on est d'accord pour
y répondre parce que c'est lui qui est à
la manœuvre la lutte informationnelle de
manière globale le séma élaborer une
doctrine avec des effets intéressants je
pense qu'il voudra y revenir sur le
soutien pour le ministre patriar le
ministre président Patriat sur le
soutien militaire à l'Ukraine bon il y a
eu plusieurs phases première phase je
reviens pas ça pourrait être rapide vous
avez rappelé les chapitres on rentre
dans un quatrième chapitre un quatrième
chapitre avec ce fond qui est une
innovation que personne n'a fait jusqu'à
présent c'est à dire en clair on ouvre
une ligne de crédit de 100 millions
d'euros aux forces armées ukrainiennes
de dire à la des françaises sur a
besoin et ces habilités des Françaises
de produire je le dis parce que ça évite
la critique du prélèvement sur le stock
de nos armées et que c'est un des moyens
aussi pour la des Françaises de
s'entraîner à la résilience et à la
réactivité d'une puissance en guerre qui
peut avoir besoin de munitions de
matériel vite donc c'est un cas pratique
que j'assume aussi parce qu'elle est
bonne pour notre BITD parce qu'elle
permet de montrer que lorsqu'on a
vraiment besoin et si nous même nous
avions vraiment besoin comment on fait
pour aller vite le président de la
République nous a demandé d'instruire de
nouvelles propositions
sur le soutien à l'Ukraine dont j'aurai
un échange discret avec le ministre de
la Défense ukrainien jeudi et les deux
présidents en vocation à se reparler
dans les jours qui viendront sur cette
aide là en tout cas
le soutien de la France s'inscrit dans
la durée pour répondre très très
précisément et pour la sénatrice
Duranton que je salue peut-être un peu
plus particulièrement la facilité
européenne de paix la part de la France
est 450 millions d'euros c'est-à-dire
que c'est pratiquement 20% 18% du budget
c'est aussi pour ça que parfois les
classements et les articles de presse
sur les classements me font sourire
parce que certains pays donnent des
choses mais qui sont remboursés par un
fond mutualiste dont la France est un
des gros contributeurs
donc je pense que on n'est pas obligé de
se faire violence la France est un gros
contributeur et oui la question de la
pérennité de la facilité européenne de
paix sera au menu des Européens dans les
temps qui viendront elle a un mérite
cette facilité européenne de paix c'est
qu'elle a permis de déclencher très vite
des sessions sans que personne n'est
trop de réticence à donner en se disant
derrière le fond viendrait
épouser le choc en quelque sorte et pour
le président Gontard un chiffre mais le
SGA lui-même répondra parce que c'est
son plan et c'est lui qui le mène
actuellement dans les équipes les armées
vont déjà pratiquement diminué leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
moins 20% ces dernières années
l'objectif ce président dans les deux
ans qui viennent c'est de diminuer de
10% notre consommation énergétique des
armées le volet opérationnel sur le
terrain c'est une chose en tout cas les
armées c'est un grand ministère
bâtimentaire et sur lequel il est clair
que les passoires thermiques sont trop
nombreuses et sur lesquelles il faut
qu'on montre encore davantage d'exemple
dans les années qui viendront mais le SG
reviendra en général
monsieur le ministre d'être juste un
complément aussi concerne les la
question concernant les le champs
informationnels donc les armées ont bien
identifié madame la sénatrice sont bien
identifiés comme critères de succès la
capacité et je vous en avais déjà parlé
il y a combiner les actions dans les
champs cinétiques et les actions dans le
champ immatériel c'est d'ailleurs un des
rétex qui est assez visible de la guerre
en Ukraine c'est à dire l'omniprésence
et l'importance de la guerre de
l'information ou les Ukrainiens
démontrent un certain savoir-faire mais
les Russes sont également très présents
donc évidemment une doctrine en ce qui
concerne la lutte informatique
d'influence qui a été qui a été présenté
l'année dernière il y a des structures
et des unités qui sont chargées de le
mettre en oeuvre et il y a aussi des
actions qui sont conduites mais qu'on
réservera peut-être dans un autre format
avec par exemple la riposte qui a été
conduite à Gossip au Mali en sur la
première partie de l'année voilà
alors je vais me permettre de répondre à
deux questions à la fois la question sur
sur Silas monsieur sénateur et également
une observation rapide donc sur
l'autonomie stratégique européenne sur
Silas alors c'est un sujet que l'on
connaît bien vous avez parlé monsieur ce
n'est que quand j'étais à l'agence de
l'innovation défense dans les financé
effectivement projet qui s'appelle map
qui était un projet de neutralisation de
drone à base d'arbre laser donc si la
fabrique entre autres des amnesia mais
beaucoup d'autres choses des systèmes de
ciblage d'illumination je rappelle pour
la commission que l'univers est aussi un
acteur qui est un fournisseur mondial de
Dieu de laser notamment pour le spatial
qui effectivement est un fournisseur de
référence et qui joue d'une très bonne
situation financière alors pour suivre
ce projet je rappelle également que nous
avons au sein de la DGA un service qui
comme son nom l'indique pas il s'appelle
le S2IE qui a le service des affaires
industriels et de l'intelligence
économique dont le but est justement de
prendre garde à que tous ces actifs
critiques et ces outils critiques pour
la base industrielle et techn de défense
qui je le rappelle compte 4000 PME en
plus des 13 au 12 ou 13 fournisseurs
majeurs soit soit préservé donc c'est
bien dans notre rôle de faire attention
et de prêter attention à ce type de
projet où est-ce qu'on en est
aujourd'hui le projet de reprise de
Silas est prêt
nous attendons l'avis de la DG
Concurrence de la Commission européenne
cet avis est attendu pour le 14 octobre
prochain il nous espérons évidemment un
avis positif qui permettra la reprise
comme vous l'avez signalez par les deux
repreneurs pressenti que sont safran et
nbda je rappelle que les actionnaires
actuels sont Ariane groupe à 63% et les
mini bird à 37%. donc
l'accéléra cible c'est quoi l'unibird
gardera ses parts ce qui devrait
contribuer à vous rassurer safran MBDA
rachète les parts d'Ariane groupe via
une co-entreprise Haddock et une fois ce
projet de session actée nous fais en
sorte qu'il y ait un des modalités de
fonctionnement permettant de conserver
cette ce développement de la filière
laser en France donc ça ce sont les
dernières informations sur sur ce projet
et donc suite je pense dans quelques
semaines mais nous prêtons une grande
attention au fait de conserver cette
cette compétence de l'univers dans
l'environnement de Silas il y avait une
question sur le l'intérêt et notamment
au vu des discussions sur le SCAF de la
coopération de l'automie stratégique
européenne alors on parle beaucoup du
skate mgcs je rappellerai quand même
qu'il y a aucune aventure industrielle
un peu ambitieuse qui se soit faite du
premier coup et sans difficulté donc là
aussi je pense nuancer un petit peu les
propos le SCAP ne met pas en péril ni
animal lui tout seul l'ensemble de la
Commission de la coopération européenne
il y a des choses que l'on doit
effectivement faire seul il y a des
choses qui si on veut qu'elles soient
suffisamment ambitieuse on peut les
faire à plusieurs il y en a pour
lesquels on n'a pas tellement le choix
je pense par exemple
dans le domaine des matériaux dans le
domaine des processeurs et bien on
pourra pas forcément faire seul et donc
il y a un intérêt évident à pouvoir le
faire en coopération je reviens pas sur
les différents outils qui sont qui sont
aujourd'hui à nos dispositions entre la
coopération structurée permanente les
dire pas les nouvelles de les nouvelles
les nouveaux instruments qui sont mis en
place ou le rôle de l'ocar simplement
revenir peut-être sur l'opportunité qui
est la nôtre aujourd'hui avec le Fond
Européen de défense qui est quand même
une première et qui est dotée de 8
milliards pour la période 2021 2027 je
dis que c'est une première parce que
c'est véritablement un fond qui est
dédié au financement de projets des
activités de recherche et de
développement pour le monde de la
défense et ça si vous souvenez il y a
quelques années ce n'était pas
véritablement à l'ordre du jour du jour
et je m'en souviens avec mon passé
d'entrepreneur de manière assez vive et
donc ce fedf va concourir effectivement
à la relance de l'économie européenne
l'enjeu majeur sur la France pour la
France c'est quoi j'ai trouvé un
équilibre entre maximiser le retour pour
l'industrie et c'est le cas d'ailleurs
avec les premiers retours qu'on a avec
avec le fedf les projets souvenirs
célestes consolider cette défenseur
européenne au travers de ces
coopérations long terme et évidemment
préservées les prérogatives nationales
clés notamment sur la définition des
besoins et sur la gestion des projets
voilà pour une réponse rapide
condition que le Fond Européen finance
bien des entreprises européennes et pas
des fauné
et nous y sommes assez sensible et
vigilants
oui monsieur le sénateur vous avez
évoqué les initiatives prises par le
ministère des armées depuis déjà un
certain nombre d'années pour réduire ses
consommations énergétiques vous avez
donné des chiffres vous avez rappelé les
ambitions qui sont qui sont réels je
voudrais peut-être compléter ces
éléments par un éclairage sur les
initiatives qui visent à accélérer
l'ensemble de cette trajectoire
d'économie d'énergie et où on retrouve
des actions de différents de différents
types
je mets d'abord d'emblée de côté la
question des enceintes militaires avec
le recours qui va être accentué
cette année et très probablement sur le
cours de la prochaine programmation
militaire au contrat de performance
énergétique qui ont des effets
extrêmement puissants en matière de
réduction de consommation dans les dans
les emprises qui sont concernées c'est
un montage qui est innovant par
l'association qui est entre
le
l'entreprise recontractante et les les
régiments les corps de troupes bref le
ministère de la Défense en tant que
affectateur de maniable mais au-delà de
cette de cette modalité qui est très
lourde du point de vue de l'ingénierie
juridique financière contractuelle il y
a toute une série d'initiatives que le
ministère adore déjà prise et qu'il va
accentuer dans les dans les mois dans
les mois qui viennent alors sur les
bâtiments un accent particulier et
d'ores et déjà mis sur une programmation
beaucoup plus systématique de petits
travaux
avant les saisons de chauffe destinées à
optimiser les consommations il y a toute
une série d'actions concernant le
remplacement systématique des ampoules
classiques par par les LED il y a des
initiatives tendantes à augmenter
l'emploi des énergies renouvelables en
plus des groupes électrogènes à la fois
sur les EMP
en métropole et
outre-mer et dans les opérations
systématiser la mise en place de suivi
de consommation donc vraiment
un bouquet un bouquet d'action et
d'initiative tous azimuts concernant les
structures bâtimentaires au sens large
et puis il y a tout un second volet qui
concerne les usages les conditions de
travail ou là le ministère et
relativement relativement leader par
rapport à des annonces et précurseurs
par rapport à des annonces que la
première ministre a faite ces derniers
jours en matière de sobriété énergétique
et qui recouvre des comportements
d'économie d'énergie concernant
concernant la température concernant
l'éclairage concernant l'éclairage
externe des emprises sous réserve du
respect des conditions de sécurité bref
toute une série de mesures qui dans le
contexte du minerme sont mises en œuvre
avec comment dirais-je un esprit de
méthode et et de systématique qui est
cohérent avec l'esprit de discipline qui
qui règne qui règne chez nous
sur le tout dernier point que vous avez
évoqué la conception nouveau type de
matériel qui serait nativement économe
en énergie je pense que le délégué
général pour le moment probablement plus
de lumière si je veux dire que moi sur
sur ces questions là
je peux vous dire évidemment sur le fait
de dire que dans la conception des
nouveaux systèmes des nouveaux systèmes
d'armes c'est évidemment un apéritif qui
sera pris en compte dans l'évaluation
des différents projets et propositions
qui nous seront faites et que de toute
manière
économiser de l'énergie est également un
avantage opérationnel il n'y a pas de il
n'y a pas d'intérêt à avoir des systèmes
qui sont gourmands en énergie bien au
contraire et donc nativement nous ne
prenions en compte et nous le prenons
d'autant plus en compte aujourd'hui y
compris dans les cycles de développement
et de production
merci
Monsieur j'ai mis ici si le chef
d'état-major des armées ou l'un des
chefs d'état-major veut compléter ses
propos pour terminer cette audition je
leur donne bien volontiers la parole
c'est patrié
de toute façon vous n'échapperez pas à
une audition spécialisée puisque
rendez-vous est pris pour
examiner un peu les crédits de vos armes
respectives
en général non
bien
ce ministre ainsi se termine cette
première audition budgétaire je crois
que tout le monde aura compris et vous
l'aurez compris vous aussi par la par
l'ensemble des questions précises qui
ont été posées par mes collègues et je
les en remercie tout ça témoigne d'une
multiplicité des sujets qu'il convient
d'évoquer et je pense que ceux-ci
sous-entend la nécessité de dialoguer
carte sur table avec le Parlement et
singulièrement avec le Sénat nous sommes
je vous l'ai dit
à titre personnel et je le redis ici
nous sommes tout à fait disponibles pour
construire le consensus un peu à l'image
de ce que nous avons fait sur une
précédente LPM dont j'étais le
rapporteur pour cette pour cette maison
je pense qu'il y a effectivement un
certain nombre de de menaces bien
évidemment qu'il convient de
parfaitement analyser il y a aussi des
défis à relever on les a évoqués pour un
certain nombre d'entre nous l'inflation
qui pèse quand même évidemment
lourdement et sur lequel vous avez levé
un coin du voile sur la manière de
contourner cet obstacle il y a aussi
bien évidemment l'épaisseur de nos
armées
la triste à faire de l'Ukraine à nous
renvoie à nos propres interrogations si
nous avons la totalité du spectre le
tout est de savoir combien de temps nous
tiendrions vous avez vu des articles de
presse
bien informés j'espère qu'ils font état
quand même de certaines faiblesses dont
il nous faut tenir compte nous ne sommes
pas là uniquement pour nous dresser des
satisfaits sites mais voir aussi où les
choses peuvent pêcher et quel travail
nous devons faire en profondeur pour
faire en sorte que notre nos forces
armées répondent à
au défi de la sécurité à la coopération
avec nos pays voisins ce qui me permet
de terminer par ce dernier point les
coopérations capacitaires au prix de
bonnes notes de
désespérance que vous avez formulé il
nous arrive parfois d'être un peu plus
sceptique que vous parce que nous
rencontrons nous aussi nos excellents
collègues
allemands et
j'espère qu'il nous entendent pour leur
dire que il faut qu'il se hâte de
répondre à nos invitations successives
pour que ce dialogue puisse être en
puisse se développer car nous savons que
dans la répartition des compétences
institutionnelles en Allemagne le
Bundestag notamment joue un rôle
essentiel il est important que nous
soyons aussi en phase nous pensons que
ce projet de Scaff pareillement le mgcs
était de bonnes idées avec un bon
équilibre dans lequel chacun des deux
partenaires devait trouver sa part il
convient que nos industriels au premier
chef se met d'accord je crois que des
discussions ont lieu sur ce sujet mais
il faut que aussi politiquement on
puisse y compris au niveau des
parlements y voir parfois un peu plus
clair parce que des déclarations telles
que celle du chef d'état-major des
armées allemandes qui a déclaré je crois
cet été qui préférait des F35 qui
roulent et qui volent à des projets
fumeux en Europe je pense qu'il faut
éclairer ce paysage et puis se parler
clairement et franchement car sinon et
c'était l'objet de ma propre question il
y a aussi des plans B qui existent la
France n'est pas dépourvue vous l'avez
dit vous-même donc il faudra évidemment
en tirer toutes les conséquences voilà
pourquoi nous restons lucides bien
évidemment
ouvert au dialogue faisons-le avec la
plus grande franchise qui a ici je crois
que nous avons
quel que soit nos sensibilités des des
amis des forces armées nous l'avons
prouvé à de nombreuses reprises et une
véritable solidarité je voudrais
terminer du reste cette première édition
budgétaire en leur disant ces forces
armées y compris à celles qui
particulièrement sont présentes à
travers différents continents que nous
sommes à leur côté que leurs besoins à
la fois en matériel et aussi en
condition de vie et de sécurité restent
au cœur de nos préoccupations et que
nous souhaitons bien évidemment que le
budget qui est le moment fort pour le
Parlement de prouver sa solidarité et
bien que ce moment budgétaire puisse
concrétiser cette attention que nous
reportons moi je note encore une fois
que les engagements pris dans la LPM
sont tenus c'est un élément très
favorable dans le contexte financier
difficile que nous connaissons et nous
espérons que la même qualité de dialogue
va s'établir pour la co-construction
tous les cas la forte participation
des sénataires et des sénatrices à ce
travail absolument essentiel pour notre
sécurité monsieur le ministre madame
messieurs les chefs d'état-major se
déléguer général Monsieur le Secrétaire
général merci infiniment de votre
participation et merci à vos équipes je
termine par une annonce paroissiale qui
qui ne concerne pas fatalement face à
concerne tout le monde bien évidemment
puisque le groupe socialiste écologique
est pu et républicain m'a fait part de
la désignation de Madame de notre
collègue Marie-Arlette Carlotti et de
notre collègue Richard themal en qualité
de vice-président de notre commission
en qualité de vice-présidente notre
commission en remplacement de nos
excellents collègues Gilbert Roger et
Jean-Marc todesquini
donc
ce ministre madame messieurs merci
infiniment